bien sans plus attendre
Mathieu plane je pense nous rejoindra
dans quelques dans quelques minutes en
même temps il connaît je pense vos
propos respectifs donc je vous propose
de démarrer sur le reportage général mes
chers collègues
mesdames messieurs en janvier dernier
nous organisons déjà une première table
ronde sur le thème de l'accélération de
l'inflation
à cette date la Banque de France
anticipée un taux d'inflation de 2,5% en
2022 en lien avec la hausse des prix de
l'énergie
dans ces dernières prévisions la Banque
de France estime que l'inflation de
l'indice des prix à la consommation
harmonisée devrait finalement atteindre
5,6%
. on peut dire que j'espère que nous
espérons que nous n'aurons pas organiser
une troisième table ronde sur ce thème
cette année
les anticipations pour l'année 2023 ont
également été relevés prévus à moins de
1,5% en 2023 par le consensus forecast
en janvier l'inflation pourrait selon
les mêmes finalement dépasser 3% selon
cela étant dit dans la situation que
nous connaissons quelle crédibilité
pouvons-nous accorder à ce type de
prévision aujourd'hui assez long terme
lors de cette de la précédente table
ronde et les économistes participants
avaient insisté sur le rôle joué par la
hausse des prix de l'énergie alors même
que le conflit en Ukraine n'avait pas
encore commencé depuis l'appareil que ce
phénomène concerne également le prix des
services de l'alimentation et des
produits magnifiques
cette accélération de l'inflation est
loin d'être sans conséquence nous le
savons tous pour l'activité économique
puisqu'elle participent à réduire le
pouvoir d'achat des ménages et le taux
de marge des entreprises et pour les
finances publiques évidemment depuis la
fin de l'année 2021 plusieurs
dispositifs ont un effet été mis en
oeuvre pour soutenir le pouvoir d'achat
des ménages bouclier tarifaire
indemnités inflation chaque énergie etc
et plusieurs autres sont proposés
actuellement dans le cadre du projet de
loi de finance rectificative pour 2022
et du projet de loi pour le pouvoir
d'achat
en parallèle nous assistons à une
remontée des taux d'intérêt nominaux et
réels des obligations souveraines sous
l'effet conjoint de la hausse de
l'inflation anticipée de resserrement de
la politique monétaire de la Banque
centrale européenne pour nous permettre
de mieux comprendre les ressorts et les
perspectives de la crise d'inflation que
nous traversons et ces ressorts et
perspectives certains en tout cas les
ressorts sont nombreux nous le savons et
nous permettre de partager la réflexion
sur la nature et l'efficacité des
réponses apportées ou qui restent à
apporter ainsi que de leur soutenabilité
budgétaire nous avons le plaisir de
recevoir ce matin plusieurs économistes
bien connues Madame Agnès Benassi kere
chef économiste de la direction générale
du Trésor que nous croisons d'ailleurs
le rapporteur général souvent d'ailleurs
en visio plus plan physique dans le cas
de la mission d'évaluation du plan de
relance
monsieur Denis Ferrand directeur général
de l'Institut rexcode monsieur Mathieu
plane directeur adjoint de l'EFCE et
enfin Monsieur Eric Chanet conseiller
économique de l'Institut Montaigne
je vous rappelle à tous que notre
audition est retransmise sur le site
internet du Sénat je vous remercie
toutes et tous de votre présence ce
matin et 700 plus attendre la parole à
Madame Agnès Benassi kere pour un poto
luminaire qui s'éveut bien ne dépassera
pas 10 minutes
[Musique]
enfin l'année dernière plutôt en fin
d'année c'était parce qu'il y avait
plutôt une anticipation de ce que l'on
était sur une inflation de nature
temporaire et non pas une mécanique
inflationniste qui s'enclenchait c'est
probablement ce diagnostic qu'il faut
que l'on a amené à réviser et il faut
apprécier dans quel ampleur ce
diagnostic doit être réviser combien
même jusqu'à présent l'inflation reste
quand même très déterminée par ce qui se
passe du côté des prix de l'énergie
pétrole gaz électricité c'est pas
seulement le pétrole on le sait bien
mais également et de plus en plus par
les prix des produits alimentaires sur
ce graphique vous avez quand vous faites
la somme des bâtons bleus et orange sur
le dernier mois connu pour une inflation
à 5,8%, vous expliquer 60% de
l'inflation par les seuls composantes
énergie et alimentation alors qu'elle
représente
25% à peu près du panier de consommation
des ménages donc on avait une toujours
une sur détermination par des chocs qui
sont de nature plutôt exogènes des chocs
sur l'alimentaire sont également en
bonne partie exogènes parce que ça tient
notamment des prix des prix des moyens
de production agricole qui sont très
fortement la hausse mais l'énergie est
un choc qui est bien plutôt d'un
mouvement de prix d'une question
d'approvisionnement mais pour autant il
y a quand même des signaux qui disent
bien qu'on a changé d'heure régime
d'inflation une manière de l'apprécier
c'est de regarder alors ce graphique est
un peu un peu complexe c'est-à-dire que
on a regardé les contributions en point
à l'inflation pour chacune des quatre
grandes composantes énergie alimentation
produits manufacturés et services et en
fait ce que la manière de lire ce
graphique consiste à regarder l'écart
qu'il y a entre la contribution
aujourd'hui et la contribution moyenne
sur longue période qui exerce chacune de
ces quatre composantes en fait on voit
que pour ces quatre composantes
l'inflation la contribution que l'on a
actuellement est bien au-delà de la
contribution moyenne qu'exerce chacun de
ces postes à l'inflation d'ensemble donc
on est passé d'un choc d'inflation très
concentré sur l'énergie un choc qui
désormais s'est répandu au-delà concerne
les prix des produits manufacturés parce
qu'il y a eu la rose des prix des
matières premières or énergie les métaux
notamment ça s'est répandu sur les
services parce qu'on a un début
d'accélération de l'ensemble du système
de prix qui a embarqué dans le dans les
prix des services et donc vous avez une
forme de diffusion de l'inflation et
cette diffusion ne semble pas devoir
s'arrêter puisque les anticipations
formulées par les chefs d'entreprise
sont toujours des anticipations de
hausse de prix et ce de manière quand
même très marquée on est à quatre
écart-types c'est une proportion qui est
tout à fait exceptionnelle quatre écart
type pour les opinions des commerçants
de détails sur l'évolution qu'ils
anticipent des prix mais ça vaut aussi
pour la construction pour l'industrie
pour le secteur des services or
qu'est-ce que représente quelle est la
qu'est-ce que aujourd'hui veut dire
cette inflation qu'est-ce que cela fait
comme amputation du pouvoir d'achat du
revenu des ménages on a essayé de faire
un calcul tout simple on n'a pas du tout
de prévision sur cette à ce stade on a
simplement regardé
l'inflation qu'on aurait constaté sur
les six premiers mois et on a fait
l'hypothèse qu'à partir de maintenant
l'indice des prix reste inchangés et ça
on l'a fait pour les pays européens que
vous avez sur sur ce tableau et donc si
il ne devait plus y avoir de nouvelles
accélération des prix à partir du mois
de juin alors sur l'ensemble de l'année
relativement à l'année 2021 le choc
d'inflation que l'on connaît
représenterait un choc excenté un choc
toutes choses égales par ailleurs de 66
milliards d'euros en France ça fait donc
66 milliards c'est ça tombe bien ça
c'est facile ça fait à peu près 1000
euros par habitant en France ça fait 4 %
du revenu des ménages 4,3% du revenu des
ménages l'énergie à elle seule c'est la
moitié de ce choc d'inflation c'est 500
euros par habitant par habitant oui pas
par ménage par habitant pour pour la
seule énergie notez aussi que cette en
France que ce choc est le plus amorti
pour l'ensemble de la zone euro ce choc
c'est 1288 euros par habitant pour
montagne on est à 1450 donc on a plutôt
plus amorti par l'intermédiaire des prix
par le jeu sur les prix en France que
cela a été le cas dans les autres pays
européens et d'ailleurs quand on regarde
sur un peu plus longue période pas
seulement sur le choc de 2000 de 2022
quand on regarde sur plus longue période
avec des prévisions de d'une inflation
qui serait en moyenne annuelle un peu
supérieure à 5% et une progression de
pouvoir d'achat du revenu des ménages de
revenus des ménages aux environs de 4%.
on va avoir une baisse sur l'ensemble de
l'année du pouvoir d'achat du revenu des
ménages mais au total par rapport à 2019
par rapport à l'avant covid la France
sera la seule des quatre grandes
économies de la zone euro à avoir un
niveau du du revenu réel des ménages
supérieurs à celui que l'on connaissait
donc avant le covid alors que on sera à
peu près 5 points en dessous pour pour
l'Allemagne deux points en dessous pour
pour l'Italie en dessous du niveau de
2019 et 5 points en dessous pour ceux
qui concerne ce qui concerne l'Espagne
et pour autant mais quand là on parle
jusqu'à présent j'ai parlé d'un pouvoir
d'achat de l'ensemble des ménages quand
ensuite on va décomposer quand on va
regarder le comportement enfin de ce que
ressentent chaque ménage pris
individuellement bien on se rend compte
qu'il y a une perte du revenu disponible
brut réel par ménage puisqu'il y a une
progression du nombre de ménages qui est
grosso modo le double de la progression
du nombre d'habitants et en 2022 il est
probable que l'on se retrouve avec un
niveau de revenus disponible brut réel
par ménage inférieur à ce que l'on avait
en 2019 mais également inférieur à ce
que l'on connaissait en 2010 à la courbe
en travers que vous avez sur sur ce
graphique donc on a bien un pouvoir
d'achat de l'ensemble des ménages qui
est au-dessus du niveau de 2019 et 10
points au-dessus du niveau de 2010 mais
en revanche il est inférieur quand on le
regarde quand on prend en compte la
structure démographique l'évolution de
la structure démographique
un autre point mais là qui est plus de
la sur de la réflexion en termes de
dynamique économique qu'est-ce que
représente aujourd'hui ce choc
d'inflation par rapport à la surépanne
qui a été constituée par les ménages
pendant la période covid donc il y a eu
abondance de formation d'épargne par les
ménages qui était empêché de consommer
mais qui ont vu plutôt leur revenu
préservé et c'est revenu ont été
épargnés et il y avait notamment une
hypothèse de voir réinjecter dans le
circuit à un moment ou un autre cette
épargne pour pouvoir stimuler la
consommation en fait c'était pas une
partie se trouve écornée se trouve
élimée par le passage de l'inflation et
donc on a estimé que ces 43% de la
surépargne qui a été constituée en 2020
2021 là encore toute chose égale par
ailleurs qui se trouve élimée par le
passage de la consommation donc si vous
voulez l'assurer épargne et bien
réintroduite par le circuit mais pas
sous forme de dépenses additionnelle
mais pour pouvoir au moins maintenir le
niveau de le niveau de dépenses des
ménages une bonne partie de se retrouver
cornée et un autre point qui nous semble
être assez important à regarder c'est ce
qui se passe du côté des dépôts réels
des ménages là ceux-ci sont en train de
sont en train de s'éroder alors face à
cela quelles sont les comportements
qu'elles sont qu'est-ce qu'on peut
imaginer en termes de de progression du
de progression du revenu et notamment du
progressions des revenus salariaux en
particulier en provenance des
entreprises je m'arrête je laisserai
Agnès compléter bien évidemment sur la
partie sur la partie étage je vais me
concentrer plus sur la partie
répercussion désormais en termes de
revenus et notamment en termes de
salaire alors ce que l'on voit déjà dans
un premier temps sur le comportement des
entreprises alors celle-ci subissent un
choc de prix en amont le choc de prix de
matière première choc de prix en fait de
l'ensemble de leurs coûts et quand on
regarde la dynamique de prix relatif et
bien on a plutôt une déformation enfin
une
un recul du prix relatif des entreprises
relativement à leur coût
d'approvisionnement et si on le regarde
avec le rapport des prix à la production
sur le prix des consommations
intermédiaires donnés par les comptes
nationaux on voit par exemple par
exemple que dans le secteur de la
construction le prix à la production ne
suit pas du tout c'est là où il suit le
moins même l'évolution des prix à la
consommation intermédiaire donc il y a
il y a un amortisseur si vous voulez qui
est pris dans les dans les marges des
entreprises de notamment par cette
intermédiaire et on le voit encore mieux
sur le sur le graphique suivant ou
compte tenu des évolutions des de la
structure de coût des entreprises on se
retrouve déjà avec un niveau de
résultats d'exploitation des entreprises
rapportées à la valeur de leur
production et non pas à la valeur
ajoutée mais un rapport à la valeur de
la production on se retrouve à des
niveaux qui sont assez proches des
points bas que l'on connaissait en
2012-2013 oui il y a eu la la forte
bosse qui est intervenue en 2021 avec
tous les dispositifs d'aide qui ont été
déployés le font de stabilisation
notamment qui ont été qui a été déployé
mais
ces dispositifs n'ont plus courts
c'est tout à fait logique enfin on est
sorti de la période ces dispositifs non
plus court
là-dessus un choc de prix de matière
première un choc de prix en amont qui
n'est pas intégralement répercuté donc
on a plutôt un recul du résultat
d'exploitation des sociétés non
financières s'ajouter à cela la question
de l'évolution des salaires alors ce que
l'on peut voir pour l'instant sur les
salaires c'est que le salaire mensuel de
base bien il progresse faiblement mais
du côté quand on regarde le salaire
moyen par tête des entreprises donc un
salaire qui va incorporer également les
primes on est sur une progression sur un
an qui est de 6,7% 3% thèmes réel mais
bon le regardez sur un an ça a pas
tellement de sens je préfère le regarder
le lycée un petit peu vous voyez les
mouvements qu'on a eu le salaire moyen
par tête avec la période covid je
préfère le regarder par rapport à 2019
le salaire moyen par tête est en
progression de 5,1% par rapport à 2019
quand on prend le niveau du premier
trimestre 2022 par rapport à la moyenne
2019 ce qui fait du 02% en termes réel
donc on a une stagnation du salaire
moyen par tête réel dans les dans les
sociétés non financières alors est-ce
qu'il y a de la place pour distribuer du
salaire ce qui fait quand même la
progression des salaires à long terme ce
sont les gains de productivité et quand
on regarde la quand on met au regard la
productivité horaire réelle dans les
branches marchandes et le salaire
horaire réel on se rend compte qu'il y a
plutôt bien moins de progression de
productivité que de progression de
salaire donc les salaires sont allés un
peu au-delà de ce que le fondamental
économique permettrait les gains de
productivité sont très en deçà de la
progression du du salaire réel quel que
soit le déflateur que l'on utilise donc
les marges d'augmentation salariale sont
dépendantes des évolutions de
productivité et pour l'instant ces
évolutions ne sont ne sont pas très
fortes pour autant qu'est-ce qui est en
train de se faire sur sur les salaires
et notamment j'insisterai sur sur la
partie de la discussion conventionnelle
des des accords des accords de branches
il y a eu une note qui était très
intéressantes qui étaient faites par la
Banque de France au mois de au mois de
mai pour essayer de positionner où on en
était en termes d'accord de branche
à la fin de l'année 2021 les
négociations sur les minimades branches
c'était une augmentation comprise entre
2,5 et 3,5 %, c'était 1% en 2021 avec
des clauses eurovoyures qui ont été
beaucoup plus fréquentes qui ont été
incorporées dans les accords de branches
qui étaient beaucoup plus fréquentes que
ce que l'on observe habituellement et
donc les closers voyeurs sont en train
de s'exercer dans un certain nombre de
range d'autant que les évolutions du
SMIC sans compter la prochaine qui va
intervenir en première août les
évolutions du SMIC font créer on fait
passer les minimas de branches en
dessous du SMIC dans dans de nombreuses
branches alors il y a quelques relations
économétriques qui sont qui sont
rappelées là-dessus ce qui fait
l'évolution enfin les
ce sont l'inflation qui est vraiment
déterminante des minimas de branches
donc on a plutôt devant nous une
accélération des minima de branches euh
c'est 06 points quand vous avez une
inflation un point vous avez 0 6 points
en moyenne d'augmentation des minima de
branches et donc on peut on peut
s'attendre à ce que comme on aura une
évolution des prix qui sera un peu
supérieure à 5 % fin 2022 il est
probable que l'accélération des minima
va se poursuivre et donc il y a une
progression régulière des régulières des
salaires sans pour autant forcément
complètement annulé l'inflation mais là
encore il y a un jeu entre les primes et
les salaires puis j'avais terminerai
juste sur un point qui était un peu en
filigrane de ce que j'évoquais sur la
comparaison du du revenu disponible brut
des ménages entre la France et les
autres pays de la zone euro on est sur
une dispersion d'inflation qui est tout
à fait exceptionnelle à l'intérieur de
la zone euro et qui va poser un moment
ou un autre des problèmes on sait que
une bonne partie de cette de cette
moindre inflation en France tient à
l'intervention directe qui a été faite
sur le niveau des prix et ce qui peut
peut-être induire si on imagine qu'à peu
près les mêmes les mêmes élasticités des
salaires pour au prix dans la plupart
des pays européens cela va induire un
une redistribution des cartes en matière
de compétitivité salariale au sein de la
zone euro sauf que cette compétitivité
salariale elle aura été notamment
permise en France par une intervention
budgétaire extrêmement importante qui va
nous mettre dans une situation de
déséquilibre budgétaire plus importante
plus dégradée que la beaucoup de pays
européens et donc ça on risque d'avoir
quand même à une nouvelle contrainte qui
va s'exercer enfin un ressentiment
peut-être dans les pays d'ordinaire qui
viendra de cette de ce décalage
d'inflation qui qui intervenu mais là
c'est juste un risque que je voulais je
voulais évoquer très bien merci Monsieur
Ferrand et vous vous avez montré que
évidemment lorsqu'on préparait un
powerpoint on pouvait gagner 5 minutes
de plus ce que nous avons donné avec
beaucoup de plaisir mais je ne souhaite
pas encourager les suivants
à prolonger dans cette durée vous nous
avez également évidemment
c'est un exposé et c'est très logique
compte tenu de l'Institut que vous
représentez euh ok un peu sous l'angle
de l'entreprise et des salariés des
entreprises bien entendu c'était ce
qu'on attendait d'ailleurs de vous dans
cette table ronde madame bensiker et
vous laissez encore votre place ou non
non donc merci beaucoup monsieur
président en fait comme ça ça va me
permettre de ne pas répéter ce qu'a dit
avec beaucoup de pédagogie Denis à un
instant peut-être pour compléter sur
certains points et puis développer
d'autres
sur le l'évolution du pouvoir d'achat
les salaires alors les salaires je pense
que il a montré des salaires par tête je
il faut peut-être les corriger par
l'activité partielle pendant la parce
que on a ce grand V en 2020 en fait
l'activité partielle ce qui fait que
c'est un peu en trompe l'oeil ce V en
réalité les salariés ont bien reçu des
rémunérations en 2020 donc c'est un peu
compliqué de calculer taux de croissance
à cause de ça
alors
là je suis vraiment complètement il faut
qu'on fasse très attention sur le fait
que on a vraiment un décrochage de la
productivité par rapport à la fin 2019
par rapport à la tendance précise enfin
prêt covid puisqu'en fait on enchaîne
les crises donc bon previd
on ne serait à peu près moins 5%. donc
c'est tout à fait important
et donc il faut mesurer l'évolution des
salaires par rapport à ça c'est à dire
si on maintient les salaires réels sur
la croissance sur la tendance
précise on a un décrochage de la
compétitivité alors soit qui ça soit qui
se prend dans les marges les entreprises
prennent dans les marges ce qui va avoir
lieu nous on n'est pas encore alarmiste
sur les marges parce que 2021 c'était un
point haut sur les marges donc on
s'attend à une diminution des marges en
effet mais pour revenir à un niveau
proche de 2018 qui est en général le
point de comparaison parce que 2019 est
un il y a le double compte cice
donc voilà je voulais remettre un peu
les choses en perspective et par rapport
au débat actuel sur sur les salaires
aussi parce que
enfin
l'État intervient sur les salaires quand
il y a une feuille de marché et il y a
classiquement une feuille de marché pour
les non qualifier puisque dans les non
qualifiés il y a un marché local du
travail avec en général quelques
employeurs dominants et des des
travailleurs qui eux sont peu coordonnés
et donc c'est une négociation
asymétrique et l'État intervient par le
salaire minimum pour empêcher le salaire
de tomber trop bas pour les salaires au
dessus du salaire minimum la concurrence
entre les entreprises surtout en ce
moment où il y a des contraintes de
recrutement et vertueuses en réalité
c'est-à-dire que certaines entreprises
vont pouvoir offrir des salaires plus
élevés attirés à elle les meilleurs
travailleurs et c'est bon pour la
dynamique de la productivité dont je
parlais tout à l'heure qui a été en
panne donc je pense que vous faire très
attention à ça que rien n'empêche les
entreprises d'augmenter les salaires
c'est elles peuvent pas descendre en
dessous du SMIC mais elles peuvent
monter au dessus on souffre en France
d'avoir une échelle de salaire qui est
très comprimé autour du SMIC qui crée un
peu de de désespérance pour les
personnes qui sont juste au-dessus qui
qui bougent pas beaucoup qui se font
rattrapés par le SMIC donc je pense
qu'il faut faire très attention quand on
commence à discuter de plus
d'interventions publiques sur les
salaires et également faire très
attention que nous sommes un pays qui a
un déficit commercial ce déficit
commercial a augmenté avec le covid il
n'a pas été rattrapé depuis certes il y
a des revenus vous avez peut-être vu les
les shis la Banque de France il y a des
revenus qui rattrapent sur le compte
courant c'est assez classique en France
bon c'est plus que ce qu'on attendait
mais il reste qu'on a un des petites
commerciales et donc c'est cette période
avec des grosses divergences d'inflation
entre les pays européens c'est peut-être
aussi une occasion pour la France de
réaliser son ajustement de prélative
qu'elle n'arrivait pas à faire avant la
crise quand il n'y avait pas de quand il
n'y avait pas de
d'inflation je vais rappeler aussi la
crise de 2009 ou en 2009 donc par
rapport à mon sujet sur la productivité
en 2009 la productivité donc avec la
crise financière la productivité a
baissé les salaires ont continué sur
leur lancée et cet écart en la pas
rattrapé il y a c'est donc le
gouvernement a dû le disons le rattraper
avec le cice et donc en tenue de la
situation des finances publiques
aujourd'hui il faut faire quand même
très attention il y aura pas un nouveau
cice pour rattraper ce décrochage donc
voilà c'est c'est la première chose que
je voulais dire sur les salaires
sur le soutien public sur le soutien
public alors on a fait des petits
calculs donc Denis a bien montré il y a
une partie qui est via moins d'inflation
et puis enfin le soutien de pouvoir
d'achat des ménages vient en partie par
les différents dispositifs blocages des
hausses de gaz d'électricité le
carburant etc enfin vous connaissez tout
ça
et l'autre partie c'est via le soutien
aux revenus l'échec bon et donc d'après
nos calculs en 2022 ce sera à peu près
moitié-moitié et le total serait presque
de 3% en France donc c'est un soutien
massif pour donner une perspective les
autres grands pays européens c'est de
l'ordre de 1 à 2%. le soutien du pouvoir
d'achat via ces différents dispositifs
donc il y a pas de miracle
il y a effectivement une situation du
pouvoir d'achat qui est meilleur en
France que dans un pays européen mais
c'est grâce à un soutien public dont ça
m'amène au sujet du soutien public
est-ce que
où est-ce qu'on va par rapport au
soutien public et aussi
peut-être donner un peu une analyse par
rapport aux discussions sur la situation
des finances publiques et le fait que
quand les prix augmentent et bien il y
aurait des recettes budgétaires et qu'on
pourrait dépenser
donc effectivement quand on regarde un
peu les choses au premier ordre on se
dit avec de l'inflation il y a plus de
recettes de TVA et donc l'État a plus
d'argent par ailleurs la dette est fixée
en euros
10% qui est indexé mais 90% qui n'est
pas indexé et donc rapporté à un PIB qui
augmente en valeur normalement ça
devrait alléger les finances publiques
alors en réalité c'est pas faux ça mais
c'est quand même une toute petite partie
de l'histoire et sans le faire trop long
donc à court terme l'OFCE l'a bien
montré à court terme comme l'indexation
des dépenses et moins rapide que
l'indexation des recettes on a
effectivement un effet positif à
quantité donnée et c'est là que manque
l'essentiel de l'histoire c'est qu'on a
un choc de terme de l'échange
c'est-à-dire qu'on fait on subit une
hausse de notre énergie importer
l'inflation elle ne vient pas d'un boom
de la demande comme c'est le cas aux
États-Unis au moins en partie chez nous
ça vient de l'inflation importer donc ça
veut dire qu'on paye plus cher donc on
fait des chèques non seulement la Russie
mais surtout au pays du Golfe et cet
argent c'est de l'argent qui va manquer
pour les caisses de l'État donc on peut
pas avoir un pays qui s'appauvrit parce
que c'est ça un choc de termes de
l'échange le pays qui appauvrit et des
finances publiques qui sont florissantes
c'est pas possible et et la raison c'est
que en volume les assiettes fiscales
diminuent relativement à avant le choc
énergétique donc la consommation les
revenus il y a des révisions des
révisions de la croissance à la baisse
et ça se retrouve dans les finances
publiques donc c'est masqué en 2022 par
des recettes exceptionnelles dont une
partie viennent du rebond de l'activité
en 21 si on pense au 7 dièse c'est donc
2021 il y a eu un rebond des profits et
donc il y a un rebond de l'IS en 2022
mais ça ça va disparaître il y a aussi
une baisse du taux d'épargne par rapport
au niveau exceptionnel de 2020 et 21
donc il a diminué un peu en 21 et de
nouveau 22 mais c'est ça peut pas
continuer éternellement donc faut faire
un petit peu attention on a des effets
qui masquent
l'effet sur les dépenses publiques et
enfin il également le fait que quand on
a un choc de termes de l'échange en fait
les prix à la consommation est donnée à
bien montrer vont plus vite que les prix
la production or les recettes fiscales
sont plus ou moins indexées sur les prix
à la production puisque c'est la valeur
ajoutée qui a ensuite partagé entre le
travail et capital et par contre les
dépenses publiques sont largement
indexées sur les prêts à la consommation
donc là on a aussi normalement en temps
normal les deux les deux prix vont à peu
près pareil mais là c'est pas du tout le
cas en ce moment et donc là aussi on a
une perte enfin sur sur la dette à court
terme donc une partie de la dette et
indexée sur l'inflation malheureusement
c'est une partie c'est 30% de
l'inflation française mais 70%
l'inflation zone euro donc comme elle va
plus vite on a un effet inflationniste
enfin un surcoût sur la dette à court
terme à plus long terme c'est
naturellement la hausse des taux qu'il
en porte et là encore sur le r moins g
il faut faire attention parce que si le
r augmente et le G augmente très bien le
taux d'intérêt moins l'auto de
croissance si les deux augmentent bon
bah ça va mais le problème avec un choc
de termes de l'échange c'est que on
risque d'avoir un R qui augmente et un G
qui diminue donc là encore on a une un
effet boule de neige qui augmenterait
alors pour terminer vous aviez une
question sur les inégalités par rapport
à les inégalités par rapport à
l'inflation que un sujet que tu as pas
trop couvert de nid juste pour aller
vite je justais les les chiffres de
l'INSEE c'était très intéressant et donc
ils ont calculé le choc d'inflation pour
différents types de ménages et donc on
voit que les habitants en zone rurale
c'est pas une surprise sont plus
exposées au choc d'inflation donc de
l'ordre de 1 point de plus donc lorsque
en
avril 2022 c'était la date de l'étude le
glissement annuel c'est 4 9 pour la
France entière et ben c'était plutôt 5 9
en zone rurale et par contre les jeunes
c'est presque un point de moins donc
c'est intéressant mais il faut faire
attention ne pas lire ça sans regarder à
côté les soutiens en revenus et
et là je vois quand même rappeler que le
SMIC a augmenté de quasi 8% aura au
moins aura augmenté en août de quasi 8%
sur un an et donc en fait les les
revenus
inférieurs sont relativement bien
protégés si on passe aussi au minimum
sociaux
en zone rural on peut imaginer aussi
qu'il y a des retraités en assez grand
nombre donc faut faire attention à ça
par rapport au soutien aux revenus là
donc un petit calcul montre que pour le
premier des cils ça représente donc les
mesures de soutien pouvoir d'achat pour
les ménages par dixième de revenus c'est
à peu près 6% du revenu pour le premier
des cils et 1% pour le dernier décide
donc tout le monde gagne et c'est l'État
qui perd mais c'est en pourcentage du
revenu évidemment en euros courant c'est
pas pareil puisque le revenu du premier
décide par définition est plus bas et
qu'est-ce que on peut attendre par
rapport aux années 70 c'était je dirais
juste là
donc on sait pas très bien les
anticipations d'inflation pour l'instant
sont ancrées la boucle presse salaire
est pas totalement enclenchée mais très
franchement c'est un peu mystérieux ce
qu'on sait par contre c'est que on est
mieux armé que dans les années 70 il y a
moins d'indexation il y a moins de
dépendance au énergies fossiles les
banques centrales sont indépendantes
il y a mais les salaires réelles sont
moins rigides mais il y a des éléments
qui peuvent quand même qui sont
différents pas forcément bien par
rapport aux années 70 il y a beaucoup
d'endettement notamment d'endettement
privé mais aussi public des tensions sur
marché du travail qui peuvent alimenter
la boucle pré-salaire une sur épargnac
accumulée on sait pas ce qui va se
passer mais elle peut être
éventuellement dépensée et donc ça ça
soutient ça soutient l'inflation voilà
je vais m'arrêter là merci beaucoup pour
votre attention merci surtout que je
vous rappelle que après nos questions
vous aurez un deuxième petit tour un peu
plus court mais qui vous permettra de
traiter les derniers points
éventuellement que vous aurez donc je
sais de maintenant la parole à Monsieur
Mathieu plane directeur adjoint de la
FCE
et je vais lui faire rajouter peut-être
si jamais il y avait pas pensé et
puisque le sujet n'a pas encore été
abordé
finalement la politique monétaire
par rapport à la lutte contre
l'inflation aujourd'hui est-ce que c'est
la bonne réponse je le pose de manière
un peu un peu raide comme ça mais est-ce
que ça répond au sujet bon mais si vous
pouvez l'intégrer dans votre je vais
essayer dans votre propos m'entendez
bien oui bonjour bonjour à tous bonjour
à toutes je vais essayer d'être bref et
évoquer effectivement ce sujet de la
réponse en fait des politiques
économiques à cette inflation qui me
semble un sujet quand même assez crucial
avec le fameux dilemme des banques
centrales entre agir pour éventuellement
donner un signal en tout cas comme quoi
le
cette inflation pouvait avoir des effets
de second tour et donc remonter les taux
clairement mais avec les effets bien sûr
que ça pourrait avoir en termes de
conséquence sur le coût de leur
financement avec ce qui a dit Agnès
l'augmentation des dettes notamment et
bien sûr les risques de casser la
croissance alors même cette inflation
beaucoup pour le moment d'origine
importée et ça c'est quand même un point
important et notamment pour la France ou
la zone euro quand on regarde
l'inflation actuelle globalement on a
peu plus de
60% qu'il y ait à l'énergie à
l'alimentaire
donc ça veut dire que l'inflation qui
est plutôt d'origine domestique reste
relativement maîtrisé ça veut dire ça
veut pas dire qu'il y a pas d'inflation
mais elle n'a rien à voir et d'où le
choc sur le poids d'achat c'est que
c'est quand même cette inflation
importée qui vient percuter de plein
fouet le pouvoir d'achat des ménages
parce que comme ça a été dit c'est pas
la hausse des revenus qui fait
l'inflation c'est la hausse des prix
importés d'où le problème des inégalités
de ce choc inflationniste qui peut être
très différent sur les situations on l'a
vu entre notamment les zones rurales
très clairement les périurbains ou les
agglomérations par exemple
l'agglomération parisienne nous on avait
fait un petit calcul à l'OFCE c'est que
sur l'inflation qui était ces témoins de
mars on avait déjà à peu près 5%
d'inflation les 10% des ménages les
mieux lotis entre guillemets face à ce
choc ils avaient une inflation à deux et
demi
les 10% des ménages les plus exposés ils
avaient une inflation à 8 et demi c'est
à dire qu'on avait déjà un écart très
fort et très clairement finalement dans
cette crise là c'est moins la question
des revenus qui va jouer que la question
de votre lieu de d'habitation
c'est à dire que au sein même d'un des
cils
prenez les plus modestes ou les classes
moyennes vous avez des situations qui
vont être très différentes d'où la
difficulté de l'intervention publique
c'est à dire vous pouvez pas faire juste
de l'ajustement selon la situation du
revenu c'est plutôt la situation
du lieu d'habitation du transport de
votre type d'énergie pour pour chauffer
etc bon je vais juste être bref c'est
que comme vous avez vu
l'origine de cette inflation elle est
d'abord et pardon à des chocs qui sont
très très spécifiques c'est à dire que
on a une crise mondiale en 2020 c'est
qui inédite depuis la Seconde Guerre
mondiale avec une reprise aussi inédite
qui déstabilise les économies avec des
problèmes entre la demande qui remonte
très fort des capacités de production
qui ont du mal à suivre on l'a vu déjà
les problèmes d'approvisionnement
existaient avant la guerre en Ukraine la
hausse des prix de l'énergie aussi et
puis derrière vous avez le deuxième choc
et la guerre en Ukraine
la problématique c'est que on pensait il
y a encore quelques mois que c'était en
fait des goulots d'étranglement c'est à
dire qu'on était face à une situation de
de choc économique très particulier avec
une reprise et que ça crée des goulots
d'étranglement et que petit à petit
c'est goulet d'étranglement elle est
disparaître avec le rétablissement des
capacités de production or en fait là où
pour nous c'est extrêmement compliqué
c'est que on est peut-être pas face à
quelque chose qui est temporaire c'est à
dire que la guerre en Ukraine conduit
probablement à des prix de l'énergie
élevés durablement on sait pas jusqu'à
quand et jusqu'où
et toute la question du gaz vous
connaissez le sujet donc quel est le
scénario du prix de l'énergie c'est
quand même fondamental et puis l'autre
point qui est nouveau aussi c'est les
stratégies adoptées par les pays pour la
réponse à la crise sanitaire
c'est-à-dire que quand le gouvernement
fait son projet de loi de finance en
octobre il y a pas au micro-ondes
au micro-ondes et donc on voit que
d'abord l'épidémie est pas forcément
derrière nous et donc ça crée des
nouveaux chocs sur l'économie mondiale
et sur les chaînes de production
mondiale et donc ça crée des tensions en
fait qui disparaissent pas et puis après
c'est la réponse à cette crise sanitaire
c'est-à-dire qu'on voit que la Chine
mais en place une stratégie zéro covid
ce qui est pas le cas de l'Europe bon
donc du coup ça ça va entretenir les
tensions donc la grande question
fondamentale et puis je vais peut-être
m'arrêter pour la discussion après
là-dessus c'est que à mon avis comme on
l'a vu pour le moment la réponse sur les
salaires elle reste assez modérée on
voit le salaire mensuel de base au
premier trimestre il augmentait d'un peu
plus de 2% alors qu'on a une inflation
qui était déjà super à 4% nous notre
prévision c'est que ça va faire 3,6 sur
les salaires mensuels de base cette
année avec une inflation à 5,3 donc en
fait ça veut dire que les salariés
perdent en point d'achat sauf les
personnes au SMIC ce qui va poser toute
la question de la distribution des
salaires pour les personnes qui sont
juste au dessus du SMIC le SMIC en moins
d'un an va augmenter de près de 8% à mon
avis ça sera assez peu le cas des
personnes sont disent 20 30 % tu donc
c'est là la question aussi sociale qui
va devoir être traité juste peut-être
pour conclure sur un certain nombre de
points pour ouvrir peut-être
la suite les principaux enjeux pour moi
bien sûr qui est déterminant c'est les
facteurs géopolitiques
et l'évolution du prix des isocarbures
typiquement les relations avec la Russie
et l'approvisionnement en gaz
effectivement si on va sur un schéma où
les prix du pétrole ou du gaz continuent
à augmenter l'inflation continueront
augmenter pour la France il y a aussi un
enjeu qui est important c'est que
effectivement on a eu moins d'inflation
que nos partenaires parce que on a eu
des boucliers parce qu'on a eu des
remises de 15 centimes avec un coup
budgétaire qui a été évoqué qui est
super aux autres pays donc il y a pas de
mystère on met plus d'argent on protège
mieux etc on gagne quand même en
compétitivité relative mais ce qu'il
faut avoir en tête c'est que du coup
quand on va ce qui peut être assez
logique c'est qu'on peut pas maintenir
ces dispositifs éternellement et qu'on
va sortir du bouclier tarifaire ou des
remises de 15 centimes ou faire du
ciblage on va réduire la voilure
budgétaire ce qui va créer un choc
inflationniste
pour les personnes qui étaient jusque là
protégées donc ce qui veut dire qu'en
2023 on peut avoir plus d'inflation que
nos partenaires dans ce cas là ce qui
peut en effet de rattrapage
l'autre point qui me semble important
c'est que
c'est effectivement l'incertitude sur
l'évolution des la gestion sanitaire des
pays voir comment est-ce que la Chine va
garder de façon durable cette stratégie
en covid qui compose pas quand même pas
mal de problèmes et puis dernier point
il y a la question de l'épargne
l'épargne accumulée qui est considérable
pour le moment qui est pas puisé alors
elle va être peut-être rognée par cette
inflation mais pour le moment elle
continue le tout départ même au premier
trimestre 2022 et encore au dessus de
son niveau d'avancer donc les ménages
sont quand même dans une phase
d'incertitude et d'inquiétude
c'est-à-dire qu'ils puissent pas dans
leur épargne on le voit pas ça tout
dépend de rester élevé et donc si se
mettait à des épargner ça ferait un rôle
de consommation mais vu l'incertitude ça
me semble assez peu probable aujourd'hui
et puis il y a les gestion du risque
inflationniste par la BCE donc vous avez
évoqué avec ce fameux lit de dilemme
entre
augmenter les taux
pour montrer qu'il y a une anticipation
sur les risques inflationnistes les
effets de second tour et que le mandat
doit être respecté et le risque ça peut
générer et d'autant plus dans une zone
euro qui est quand même assez fragile
sur cette question là parce qu'on a
toujours ses risques de fragmentation de
la zone euro avec l'Italie qui est plus
exposé en cadre montée des taux et ces
fameux
r moins g ou j'ai moins r n' en parler
Agnès juste avant qui est l'écart entre
la croissance et les taux d'intérêt
c'est à dire qu'effectivement quand
votre croissance est plus forte que vos
taux d'intérêt ça vous permet de vous
désendetter sans faire trop d'efforts
l'inverse c'est l'effet boule de neige
c'est que votre charge d'intérêt
augmente plus que votre recette fiscale
donc ça c'est extrêmement important donc
le dilemme dans zone euro il est quand
même assez différent de celui des
Etats-Unis c'est clairement des taux
aussi créer des spreads c'est-à-dire des
écarts entre pays qui peut être beaucoup
plus fort et dont l'ABC va devoir gérer
elle est censée elle va mettre un outil
anti fragmentation en place qu'on attend
beaucoup mais le dilemme se rajoute à
toutes ces problématiques mais dernier
point et j'arrête là si on dit qu'il y a
pas de restables sur les prix de
l'énergie imaginons ça dès qu'on
retrouve une situation sanitaire à peu
près normale moi je crois qu'on sera pas
dans la boucle prix salaire de la
stagnation des années 70 qui a duré 10
ans des indexations c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui les les salaires sont pas
indexés automatiquement l'a BCE a quand
même un mandat très clair à
l'indépendance et les pays sont quand
même très ouverts sur le commerce et en
compétitivité donc ça limite quand même
ses effets de second tour qu'on pouvait
avoir autrefois ce qui veut dire que à
court terme ça fait quand même un choc
négatif aussi sur le port d'achat et
donc c'est la question sociale à court
terme qui va devoir être traitée merci
merci lorsque vous aurez la parole une
deuxième fois vous essayez de nommer
votre point de vue à vous sur une si
vous étiez le gouverneur de la Banque la
BCE qu'est-ce que vous feriez voilà
entendre des voilà
c'est un beau mandat oui ne le refusez
pas pour quelques instants
monsieur Chanet s'il vous plaît pour une
dernière intervention pour l'Institut
Montaigne merci monsieur le Président et
bonjour à tout le monde mesdames et
messieurs alors je représente pas
l'Institut Montaigne je te tiens à le
préciser je conseille l'Institut
Montaigne mais les vues que je vais
partager avec vous qui sont plus
générales que celles de mes collègues
sont personnels je vais d'abord vous
parler de la dimension mondiale de
l'inflation revenir un petit peu sur les
causes de l'inflation vous expliquer
pourquoi je suis un petit peu plus
inquiet à propos de la France que
certains de ses partenaires sur la
possibilité d'une inflation durable et
réfléchir un peu au moyen que les
politiques publiques peuvent et le tour
en 10 minutes ce qui va être en 10
minutes
je n'oublierai pas la BCE même si je ne
prendrai certainement pas la casquette
de sa président d'abord le retour de
l'inflation c'est vraiment un phénomène
mondial
et d'ailleurs avant avant même que
l'inflation redevienne un sujet
de débat dans le grand public et pour
les politiques c'était un débat chez les
économistes il y avait en gros deux
camps il y avait ceux qui disaient bon
il y a un excès d'épargne mondial c'est
le savinglot dont parlait ben Bernard
qui et donc on est condamné à une
inflation très basse et à des taux
d'intérêt très bas pour encore quelques
milliers d'années ou quelques vingtaines
d'années quelques dizaines d'années faut
pas non plus exagérer et puis il y avait
ceux qui disaient oui mais il y a déjà
une certaine accélération de natation
aux États-Unis nous sommes rentrés dans
une période de
démondialisation alors qu'il n'est pas
brutale mais tous les bénéfices de la
mondialisation qui étaient de la
désinflation sont inversées et c'était
un débat un peu académique mais il y
avait une chose sur lequel tout le monde
était d'accord parce que beaucoup de
travaux statistiques l'avaient prouvé
c'est que l'inflation c'est mondiale
alors je citerai une étude qui date de
2010 de Benoît Mojon et de chicarelli
qui montrait que pour un très grand
échantillon des pays de l'OCDE et sur
longue période 60% de l'inflation
lorsqu'elle monte ou lorsqu'elle descend
c'est une composante mondiale c'est le
cycle économique mondial c'est les
matières premières donc l'inflation
c'est un point sur lequel tout le monde
était d'accord y compris ceux qui
pensaient qu'elle avait un risque qui
pensaient qu'il y en avait pas c'est
mondial et c'est bien ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui alors d'où vient l'inflation
qui nous préoccupe aujourd'hui c'est
clairement un choc d'offres c'est
l'incapacité de l'appareil de production
mondiale à suivre la reprise post covid
qui a été plus forte anticipée les gens
n'ont pas pu dépenser ils se sont mis à
dépenser et puis un deuxième choc d'Off
qu'il y est que il y a moins d'énergie
d'énergie fossile en particulier
produite que prévu et donc si l'offre
réduite et que la demande est toujours
là on a un choc inflationniste et qui
part définition
doit s'appeler de la stagnation
puisqu'il y a moins d'activités et des
prix plus élevés ça s'appelle de la
stagnation alors j'apprécie ce que
Mathieu a dit la staccation c'est
lorsqu'elle devient endémique que ça
devient véritable problème mais la
situation dans laquelle nous sommes
aujourd'hui et véritablement une
situation stagnationniste
alors si c'est un choc d'offre
les chocs un peu par définition cette
transitoire parce qu'il y a des signaux
prix qui sont particulièrement violents
regardez le prix d'électricité le prix
du gaz etc et s'il y a une chose qu'on a
appris dans l'histoire économique c'est
que les économies en tout cas les
économies de marché elle s'adapte en 73
en 79 on a eu des chocs pétroliers
massifs quel a été le résultat une
incitation très forte à investir dans la
recherche de pétrole de gaz de nouvelles
techniques d'extraction et en avalent
dans des économies beaucoup moins
gourmandes en pétrole donc l'offre
s'adapte mais il lui faut du temps et
c'est précisément là où se pose le
problème de la possibilité d'un régime
inflationniste l'offre s'adaptera
si ça lui prend 10 ans et bien pendant
10 ans on a un risque d'inflation si
elle est auto-entretenue
le régime d'inflation dont je crois
Denis nous a un petit peu parlé en nous
montrant les différentes composantes de
l'inflation et c'est là où j'en viens à
mon troisième point il y a des
particularités en France qui me font
penser que le risque d'une inflation
peut être plus basse mais plus durable
et significatif en France
il y a deux canaux par lesquels on peut
passer à un régime d'inflation plus
durable le premier ce sont les
anticipations ça c'est bien clair si les
salariés et les patrons pensent que
l'inflation est durable les premiers
demanderont des salaires plus élevés et
les autres sachant qu'ils pourront
augmenter leur prix auront peu de raison
de leur résister si en plus il y a une
pénurie de à l'embauche c'est une
incitation plus en plus à augmenter les
salaires donc ça c'est de l'anticipation
les gouvernements ne peuvent pas grand
chose là-dessus il y a des mécanismes
sur lequel je reviendrai l'indexation
mais c'est quand même principalement le
rôle des politiques monétaires de faire
en sorte que ce soit clair pour tout le
monde les consommateurs les salariés les
entreprises nous respecterons notre
objectif de 2% d'inflation qui est
maintenant devenu commun à toutes les
banques centrales dans le monde depuis
que la BCE a enfin accepté que ce ne
soit pas 1,99 mais
2%. donc les anticipations c'est une
question de politique monétaire mais il
y a un deuxième mécanisme qui peut
rendre l'inflation plus durable ce sont
les mécanismes d'indexation alors ils
ont peut-être été réduits par rapport à
ce qui était l'indexation de fait
lorsque les économènes gardaient la
boucle pré-salère dans les années 70 et
80 mais nous avons en France pas
seulement c'est aussi le cas de l'Italie
de l'Espagne et de la Belgique là il y a
une espèce de consortium de pays où il y
a une forte indexation des salaires et
en France ça passe quand même
essentiellement par le SMIC et ceci nous
donne un risque d'inflation
auto-entretenu puisque c'est plus fort
en France que ça ne l'est par exemple en
Allemagne le risque est plus élevé alors
je fais juste un petit une petite insert
sur la situation relative de la c'est de
l'Allemagne la situation de l'Allemagne
et surtout de l'Italie et bien pire que
celle de la France tout simplement parce
que leur dépendance au gaz russe est
bien supérieure donc le choc
inflationniste et le choc plus fort de
ce point de vue là la France si je peux
dire dans une bonne position relative
mais le risque que l'inflation dure plus
longtemps et plus importante en
Allemagne où il n'y a aucune indexation
des salaires des salaires comme vous le
savez en Allemagne sont purement laissés
à la négociation entre les syndicats et
le patronat
quand on a une contrainte d'offre comme
je l'ai décris maintenir le pouvoir
d'achat des salaires c'est très bien
mais ceci veut dire que d'une certaine
manière on entretient l'inflation par un
autre biais si la production ne peut pas
augmenter parce qu'il y a pas de pétrole
qui a pas assez d'électricité bref qui
est des contraintes que les
semi-conducteurs vous n'allez pas les
inventer ça pousse pas bien dans les
champs et que vous maintenez le pouvoir
d'achat vous maintenez la demande alors
que l’offre ne peut pas suivre et donc
c'est quelque chose à garder en tête il
y a des tas de bonnes raisons pour avoir
des politiques de maintien du pouvoir
d'achat il faut avoir en tête que ça
fait partie des mécanismes aussi qui
entretiennent l'inflation en ne
permettant pas à la demande de descendre
au niveau de l'offre
alors comment réduire je dirais pas le
choc inflationniste mais plutôt ça
durait donc la première question c'est
est-ce que le gendarme qu'est la Banque
centrale européenne est équipée pour ça
et ce qu'elle fait ce qu'il faut
elle nous garantit que l'inflation
restera à 2% à moyen long terme alors
c'est très sage de dire moyen long terme
parce que les pics que ce soit
d'inflation ou de déflation ne sont pas
des choses sur lesquelles la politique
monétaire peut grand chose de plus la
politique monétaire ne peut pas
fabriquer d'électricité ou de gaz donc
quand on a un choc d'offres on comprend
que la banque centrale soit très
prudente avant de se dire oh là là il
faut que je remonte mes taux d'intérêt
oui mais
est-elle crédible lorsqu'elle nous
garantit qu'à long terme on restera à
2%. et c'est là où on peut avoir quand
même quelques doutes et la problématique
a été soulignée par Mathieu en
particulier il est clair que
la politique quantitative de la Banque
centrale européenne dont je rappelle que
le but était de faire baisser les taux
d'intérêt à long terme
donc de stimuler la demande en espérant
que ça ferait remonter l'inflation
c'était l'idée cette politique quantité
de déterminée puisque on ne cherche pas
maintenant à faire baisser l'inflation
or cette politique quantitative il faut
appeler un chat un chat c'est ce qui a
complètement annulé le risque de crédit
de pays plus faible et quand on dit pays
plus faible bien c'est une espèce de
cache sexe pour parler de l'Italie donc
la prime
de crédit que les investisseurs qui sont
les épargnants normalement demande
lorsqu'ils ont des doutes sur une
économie a été totalement éradiquée par
la politique quantitative de la BCE
pendant plusieurs années toutes les
émissions du Trésor italien étaient
achetées quasiment directement par la
Banque centrale européenne donc le
marché était incapable de donner un prix
à ce risque de crédit tout ceci est
terminé la politique tentative n'a plus
aucun sens puisque l'inflation est là et
donc le risque de crédit réapparaît avec
le risque d'anticipation
auto-réalisatrice si les marchés vont
trop loin c'est à dire que la situation
devient de pire en pire et que le risque
de crédit qui était peut-être des petits
au départ pourrait devenir beaucoup plus
important et donc vraiment le dilemme
est très compliqué pour la Banque
centrale européenne ce qui est pas du
tout le cas de la Fed de la Banque du
Japon ou de la Banque d'Angleterre c'est
à dire politique tentative s'est
terminée donc je ne peux plus cacher le
risque de crédit de l'Italie et de
quelques autres pays j'espère que la
France n'en fera pas partie d'un autre
côté il faut quand même que je un peu
méthodes d'intérêt pour m'assurer que
tout le monde a bien compris ces 2% à
long terme oui mais le faisant j'aggrave
la situation donc la BC nous dit mais
nous on est déjà très astucieux on va
inventer on va dire je crois que ça sera
présenté cet après-midi peut-être que
certains d'entre nous connaissent déjà
le nom de l'instrument on aura un
instrument pour empêcher la
fragmentation c'est-à-dire ce que ce
risque de crédit sur l'Italie est
quelques autres pays deviennent trop
importants pour que la zone euro reste
gérable et en même temps on lutte contre
l'inflation je peux vous dire qu'il
risque d'y avoir un certain scepticisme
il faut être
écoutez ce que la BCE va nous dire mais
il y a quand même un risque de
crédibilité donc sur cette question de
l'ancrage des anticipations d'inflation
le gendarme n'est pas forcément le plus
crédible qu'on puisse imaginer alors il
y a un deuxième élément je voudrais
signaler sur le traitement de
l'inflation et qui ne dépend pas
directement des politiques économiques
c'est la conjoncture
est-ce que la conjoncture pourrait
régler notre problème
si il y a une récession
les récessions c'est l'arme
anti-inflation
ultime si je puis dire ça pas toujours
été le cas mais ça risquerait de l'être
or de mon point de vue je ne suis plus
un conjonctureiste qui est vraiment les
mains dans le cambouis mais je l'ai été
suffisamment longtemps pour faire
attention à tous les signaux qui
viennent des enquêtes de conjoncture et
pas seulement en France mais aux
États-Unis et je vois que les
anticipations des entreprises c'est très
clair en Allemagne mais c'est clair en
France aussi et c'est clair aux
États-Unis depuis trois mois sont en
train de dégringoler il y a de bonnes
raisons pour ça il y a ce choc d'Off qui
est extrêmement important il y a la
risque de pénurie d'énergie et il y a ça
n'a pas encore été mentionné mais c'est
extrêmement important une forte
dégradation des conditions financières
de financement des économies et du
secteur privé essentiellement la chute
du marché d'action c'est 17% depuis le
début de l'année pour le pour le SP 500
pour l'indice américain un peu moins
pour le CAC 40 mais l'euro c'était
pressé mais surtout l'écartement des
spreads de crédit ce qu'on appelle les
spreads de crédit ce que doivent payer
en termes de taux d'intérêt en plus les
entreprises par rapport aux États qui
vous avez peuvent toujours
taxer leur leur contribuables et
renouveler leur dette qui est pas le cas
des entreprises or les spreads de crédit
s'écarte énormément ce qui est tout à
fait normal puisqu'il y a un
renversement des politiques monétaires
donc le financement des entreprises que
ce soit par le marché des actions que ce
soit par le marché obligataire et
progressivement parce qu'elle s'aligne
par les banques devient plus difficile
quand il y a un resserrement des
conditions financières qu'il y a un choc
d'offre quand vous dit et il y a juste
titre qu'il risque d'y avoir des
pénuries il est normal que les
entreprises se disent ça risque de mal
se passer moi il me semble que la
probabilité d'une récession aux
États-Unis et en Europe je me
prononcerai pas pour la Chine
puisqu'elle était déjà en récession en
deuxième trimestre et que ça dépend
beaucoup de leur politique mais en tout
cas pour ces deux zones absolument
essentielles pour les prix en général
cette probabilité d'une récession disons
à l'horizon de 6 mois est assez
importante
si cette
ce résultat qui n'est quand même pas
souhaitable se réalise les prix des
matières premières baisse les
anticipations d'inflation aux États-Unis
sont déjà en chute libre parce que les
marchés anticipent une récession donc
les prix des matières premières baisse
et lorsque vous avez une récession et
bien il y a moins d'incitation à avoir
des revendications salariales puisque la
préservation de l'emploi devient plus
importante donc évidemment je ne
souhaite pas que ce soit une récession
qui règle notre problème mais je vous
signale que ça fait partie des choses
qui sont peut-être dans les cartes alors
est-ce qu'il y a quand même des moyens
positifs bien entendu qu'il y en a
limité le risque d'inflation salariale
donc ça c'est très important pour éviter
l'enclenchement de la boucle pré solaire
peut se faire en réduisant
temporairement les charges salariales ce
que les salariés ce qui intéresse les
salariés ce n'est pas le coût du travail
c'est le salaire qu'il reçoive par
contre les entreprises elles fixeront
leur salaire plutôt par rapport aux
coûts salariales et donc si
contrairement je crois que c'est la voix
qui est choisie par l'Allemagne on
réduit les charges ceci permet de
préserver le salaire qui est directement
perçu sans que le coût du travail
augmente et donc sans déclencher cette
dynamique alors évidemment il y a un
défaut mais qui est toujours le même si
on cherche à préserver le pouvoir
d'achat et bien on maintient la demande
alors que l'offre de la peine à suivre
mais il n'y a pas de politique de
pouvoir d'achat qui n'encourt pas cette
critique donc il faut faire avec la
deuxième façon de procéder c'est celle
qui est largement employée par quasiment
tous les pays mais en France encore plus
qu'ailleurs c'est limiter l'augmentation
des prix de l'énergie et ça c'est une
politique intelligente parce que
justement elle réduit le risque
d'accélération des salaires et donc
d'inflation qui devient plus
auto-entretenue elle a deux défauts mais
à nouveau on ne peut pas avoir le beurre
l'argent du beurre et le sourire de la
crémière le premier c'est que ça
maintient une demande pour des produits
énergétiques
dont l'offre est réduite le deuxième
c'est que ça a un impact sur les
finances publiques mais là Agnès Benassi
en a parfaitement bien parlé
alors il y a un troisième point que je
voudrais signaler dans les politiques
qui peuvent t'aider c'est de réduire la
demande de produits énergétiques parce
que c'est quand même notre problème
numéro 1 et il y a des propositions qui
sont faites par l'Agence internationale
de l'énergie qui ont été publiées à
quelques jours 5 points tous cette
exprimé dans un langage très
diplomatique bien entendu mais en gros
ça nous dit il est temps de penser au
rationnement il est temps de penser à où
va-t-on réduire d'une manière peut-être
autoritaire la demande quand il y a un
déséquilibre offre demande en gros ça ne
se résout que de deux façons qui ne sont
pas d'ailleurs contradictoires la
première c'est les prix si ça devient
très cher les gens achètent moins la
deuxième c'est de dire bah désolé voilà
vous aurez droit à telle quantité que ce
soit pour les industriels ou que ce soit
pour les ménages l'Allemagne a choisi
cette solution là et je crois comprendre
qu'elle est déjà même assez bien avancée
pour l'explic le plan de rationnement
nous ne sommes pas en France dans une
situation aussi difficile parce que nous
avons une offre d'énergie qui est
beaucoup plus diversifiée et qui dépend
moins du gaz russe mais il me semble
qu'il faut dire des choses aujourd'hui
commencer à travailler sur des
politiques de rationnement ce serait de
la bonne politique y compris pour
limiter l'inflation le point commun de
tout ce que j'ai cité c'est que on va
aller vers la conclusion temporaire
temporaire justement ma conclusion c'est
qu'il y a des politiques qui ne sont pas
temporaires si on a un problème d'offre
les meilleures politiques c'est
d'augmenter l'offre et en particulier
l'offre d'énergie non carbonée bien
entendu alors c'est évidemment des
politiques de moyens long terme mais
c'est pas parce que c'est du moyen long
terme que ça ne vaut pas le coup de les
mettre en oeuvre immédiatement car des
chocs d'offres
nous en avons un quai massif qui est
multidimensionnel aujourd'hui mais rien
exclut qu'il y en ait d'autres dans le
futur donc travaillons tout de suite sur
le long terme excusez-moi d'avoir été un
tout petit peu trop long monsieur le
Président très bien merci beaucoup en
tout cas je peux vous dire que c'est 4
exposés étaient de grande qualité et que
à ma grande surprise ils ne se sont pas
contredits
donc
globalement globalement il y a des
appréciations nuancées et heureusement
mais c'était très complémentaire je vous
en remercie bien monsieur le rapporteur
général pour les premières questions oui
merci monsieur le Président en tous les
cas ça démontre et on se le disait en
aparté
que l'inflation telle qu'on la connaît
aujourd'hui
n'obéit pas tout à fait au canon de ce
qu'on a pu nous enseigner il y a encore
quelques années alors je partage assez
les chiffres que vous avez donné sur
l'origine alors c'est évidemment
principalement la question des énergies
dont je rappelle que le coût
pour la direction du Trésor je pense que
c'est important le coût de l'énergie
pèse relativement lourdes dans le
déficit budgétaire et d'un déficit
commercial de la France
il fut un temps c'était un peu plus de
50% là on est autour de 38 40%. donc
dans les orientations
que les pouvoirs publics l'exécutif et
peut-être le Parlement aura à prendre il
y a sur ce sujet une réorientation alors
je j'ai bien entendu le prêt à
République faire un virage à 180 degrés
par rapport au nucléaire mais je crois
qu'il n'y a pas que ça
ce qui m'amène quand même à dire que il
y a eu je pense des décisions et des
choix malheureux qu'on va porter pendant
un certain temps et vous parliez
effectivement d'énergie décarbonée
voilà il y a vraiment de la difficulté
et beaucoup de travail devant nous moi
je voulais revenir alors je voulais
poser la question sur est-ce que les uns
les autres vous pensez que cette
inflation va être durable
deux d'entre vous ont déjà répondu
donc je maintiens néanmoins la question
peut-être plus pour Madame bénéfique
et puis je vais revenir sur
l'objet de cette table ronde c'est
essayer de comprendre
avec les phénomènes inflationnistes
actuels les conséquences sur le pouvoir
d'achat et à l'aune des mesures
proposées par étape par le gouvernement
avec une nouvelle étape parce que ça
commence enfin c'est pas un tour de
France mais ça ressemble
il y a même je pense que parfois il y a
des contradictions il y a des manques de
ciblage moi je pense effectivement que
vous avez évoqué plutôt la France rurale
et puis parfois également les
contraintes en milieu en milieu urbain
et également sur les les plus basses
rémunérations donc par rapport à tout ça
[Musique]
et avec les mesures qui sont annoncées
aujourd'hui
n'y a-t-il pas une forme de confusion si
je prends la prime exceptionnelle de
pouvoir d'achat qui devrait devenir la
prime
de protection de la valeur le partage de
la valeur oui
moi j'ai le sentiment qu'elle de elle
s'annonçait temporaire mais pour devenir
pérenne
d'ailleurs dans le fractionnement ça
voudrait dire qu'il y aura un nouveau
dispositif si on est pour combattre
essayer de combattre un pic d'inflation
une matière un pouvoir d'achat ça
devrait donc être temporaire donc
comment les mesures obéissent selon vous
est-ce qu'elle réponde bien
à ce phénomène qui était espéré comme
temporaire parce que si on répond de
manière temporaire à un phénomène plus
durable on risque de frapper à côté de
la cible et donc de désorienter nos
concitoyens
et puis
dernier élément et peut-être pour nous
en notre mission des finances le plus
important c'est tout ça a pris tout ça
un coup
un coup très lourd pour nos finances
publiques
comment
pensez-vous que l'on puisse répondre de
la meilleure des manières sur l'impact
budgétaire la dégradation de la plupart
de nos agrégats budgétaires et de
finances publiques et puisqu'on est au
Sénat j'ajoute que comme le prénom
République avait annoncé mettre comment
dirais-je une réduction supplémentaire
de 10 milliards sur les moyens accordés
par l'État aux collectivités locales
quand celle-ci
ont fait face à cette période sans
dégradation de leur ratio comment est-ce
que vous imaginez la suite c'est-à-dire
éviter une dégradation peut-être
importante j'espère pas funeste notre
économie et de notre évidemment de nos
ratio budgétaires
merci monsieur le rapporteur général
nous allons passer aux autres questions
de nos collègues pour faire une réponse
groupée alors règle du jeu je vous
donnerai donc si vous le voulez bien 5
minutes à chacun sur les réponses que
vous souhaitez prendre en charge bien
sûr les uns les autres
vous les répartir un petit peu et puis
d'autre part vous serez dans l'ordre
inverse c'est à dire que c'est Monsieur
Chenet qui démarrera les réponses
monsieur plane etc voilà donc ceci étant
dit je fais appel toujours comment dire
à la concision de mes collègues dans les
questionnements et nous démarrons avec
Didier Rambaud qui va nous montrer
comment faire
merci président pour ce défi que vous me
lancez alors c'est une question qui
concerne le lien entre la hausse du SMIC
et les minimas à la rue tout à l'heure
donc de différents a rappelé qu'avec la
hausse du SMIC au 1er mai trois quarts
des branches ont vu leur minima repasser
sous le SMIC j'avoue que j'étais assez
interpellé par cette alors peut-être
davement par cette cette remarque et
donc ma question c'est de savoir est-ce
qu'il a est-ce que à la louche ça
concerne combien de salariés en France
est-ce que c'est ennuyé ou est-ce que
c'est en millions quels sont les types
de branches qui sont particulièrement
concernés par cela et je fais le lien
avec la question d'aujourd'hui du du
sujet des emplois non pourvu parce que
comme vous tous je suis impressionné
voir par moment agacé quand je traverse
mon département de voir dans un grand
nombre de zones d'activités affichées
partout ici on recrute donc voilà est-ce
que est-ce qu'on peut faire un lien avec
tout ça et puis je dirais alors une une
question globale pour l'ensemble des
intervenants puisqu'on parle de pouvoir
d'achat et d'inflation ce matin que vous
le savez donc un projet de loi qui a qui
est en examen actuellement à l'Assemblée
et prochainement au sein sous le pouvoir
d'achat et l'inflation quel est votre
regard sur ce projet de loi
pouvoir d'achat merci merci
Didier Vincent capo canela
merci merci président d'abord une
première question sur le constat parce
que Monsieur Ferrand j'ai été frappé moi
par les je crois que les planches 11
vous nous dites que le salaire moyen des
sociétés non financières à augmenter de
6,7% sur un an ce qui paraît
considérable évidemment ça concerne
qu'un type de situation
vous nous dites aussi je crois au début
de votre présentation que la France est
la seule des principales économies dans
le pouvoir d'achat sera supérieur à 2019
mais ensuite après pachette vous faites
la distinction entre pouvoir d'achat et
revenu disponible par contre le revenu
disponible brut il est inférieur à celui
de 2019
et même de 2010
bon ça c'est par ménage mais on
gagnerait à partager un constat commun
parce que lorsque j'écoute monsieur
plane l'approche est un petit peu
différente et les plus critique sur le
fait que il y a un problème de pouvoir
d'achat mais déjà sur ce constat là
est-ce qu'on est-ce qu'on peut
s'entendre clairement bon mais vous nous
avez rappelé que il y avait un effet de
concentration des revenus autour du SMIC
alors ça peut vous paraître basique
comme question est-ce que vous pouvez
nous redire en quelques mots les raisons
et quel problème ça pose puisque on voit
bien c'est un peu une spécificité
française comment on peut en sortir de
cet élément là parce que si on veut du
pouvoir d'achat c'est peut-être régler
cette affaire là et enfin Monsieur
monsieur plane vous avez parlé de
l'importance de la situation
géographique alors j'ai pas entendu trop
dans les différents exposés la question
du poids du logement mais il me semble
que en zone métropolitaine depuis des
années l'augmentation du prix du
logement est à un effet considérable sur
le pouvoir d'achat mais défoliant et que
depuis le covid partout sur le
territoire le prix du logement a
augmenté est-ce qu'il y a pas un sujet
spécifique qu'il a mériterait une
réponse qui n'existe pas aujourd'hui
alors qui est difficile à bâtir mais
voilà dernier point Éric Chanet vous
vous dites baissez les charges bon très
bien mais comment comment le finance
merci Vincent Michel canvet puis Bernard
delco merci monsieur le Président je
revois aussi remercier les éclairages de
nos interlocuteurs ce matin à la Rania
siceri a évoqué le décrochage de la
productivité est-ce qu'on peut
identifier les causes de ce décochage la
plus de la côte de la productivité
est-ce que c'est lié au covid est-ce que
c'est lié à l'emploi est-ce que c'est
lié à des difficultés
d'approvisionnement principalement à ce
qu'il y a d'autres facteurs qui qui
jouent comme l'ont dit mes collègues on
va avoir l'examen de la loi sur le
pouvoir d'achat alors on s'aperçoit
quand même que qu'en France la situation
est plutôt pas mal par rapport à
d'autres économies c'est-à-dire que nos
concitoyens au moins souffert mais le la
contrepartie c'est qu'effectivement ce
sont des déficits publics considérables
en plus est-ce qu'on peut continuer en
ce sens c'est ce que par exemple sur
l'aide au carburant tout on voit bien
qu'il faut réduire la quantité on a
parlé tout à l'heure de rationnement
est-ce qu'on peut continuer comme ça à
l'aide de réaliser au carburant est-ce
qu'il faut pas rapidement ressembler et
est-ce que les propositions qui sont
formulées vont vraiment atteindre la
cible c'est à dire qu'on a évoqué tout à
l'heure aussi le fait que ce soit les
zones rurales qui soient les plus
pénalisées aujourd'hui et peut-être
faudrait-il encore me cibler les choses
troisième sujet qui concerne la question
des exportations est-ce que la
l'évolution négative très négative de la
balance commerciale et donc de la
balance des paiements
risquent de poser problème un problème
sérieux pour l'avenir qu'est-ce que vous
en pensez et puis quatrième et dernière
question
d'Italie est en situation
particulièrement préoccupante au plan
politique et risque d'avoir une
influence aussi au plan financier est-ce
que cela peut amener des difficultés à
notre pays pour pouvoir se financer
compte tenu de l'importance des déficits
publics aujourd'hui est-ce que cela peut
avoir une difficulté pour pouvoir
financer notre tête merci Michel Bernard
delcro oui mais merci merci à nos
intervenants j'ai trois questions
monsieur plane vous avez évoqué la
question de l'écart entre les taux
d'intérêt et les taux de croissance et
évidemment l'impact que cela sur la
soutenabilité de la dette et du coup
vous paraît-il possible aujourd'hui de
tracer des perspectives en termes de en
terme de croissance deuxième question
vous avez évoqué également l'épargne qui
est important
serait-il possible selon vous de mettre
en place des mesures spécifiques pour
mobiliser cette épargne et enfin Madame
Benassi Quéré vous avez évoqué
plus particulièrement l'inflation qui
touchait certains territoires plus que
d'autres les habitants notamment des
territoires ruraux évidemment on peut le
comprendre et selon vous serait-il
possible et justifié d'ailleurs de
mettre en place des mesures spécifiques
pour tenir compte de l'impact
particulière de l'inflation de la vie je
crois un point de plus on peut l'estimer
environ un point de plus pour les
habitants de territoire ruraux
merci Bernard Vanina paoliga puis
Thierry Cozic
oui monsieur le Président merci merci
aux intervenants qui nous ont fait des
présentations de grandes qualités ma
question se dresse plutôt à Monsieur
plane elle concerne la revalorisation
prochaine au premier août du taux du
livret A qui va remonter à 2% qui reste
tout de même bien dans de cela de
l'inflation on sait que c'est un taux
qui est quand même un pouvoir
d'indicateur
psychologique très fort et donc je
voulais savoir si vous avez une idée de
l'impact que ce rehaussement pourrait
avoir éventuellement notamment sur
l'investissement dans le secteur privé
et puis je rebondis sur la question de
mon collègue delcro sur la mobilisation
de la surépargne coïd puisque je pense
effectivement qu'il faudrait qu'une
partie de cette épargne puis c'est
injectée dans notre économie notamment
en faveur de la transition écologique on
en a parlé au sein de cette commission
mes chers collègues via une proposition
de
que j'ai faite dans un climat où on me
disait que il y avait pas de risque de
rehaussement des taux d'intérêt
merci Vanina Thierry cosi puisse belles
briquet merci monsieur le Président
merci à l'ensemble des orateurs de cette
introduction alors deux questions les
deux points déjà été soulevés par mes
collègues le premier c'est sur le la
relation entre l'inflation et l'épargne
et notamment sur le livret A comme lien
de l'évoquer
Vanina à l'instant aujourd'hui il y a
80% des Français qui ont un livret A ce
qui représente à peu près 55 millions de
personnes
c'est le placement qui est privilégié
par les foyers modestes
pour rappel il y a 60% des livréas qui
ont aujourd'hui un encourt inférieur à
1500 euros
avec la hausse des prix cela fait fondre
la valeur des économies des détenteurs
je reprends les propos de Thomas
appliquetti qui qui dit l'inflation
prend la forme d'un impôt très lourd sur
l'épargne populaire donc je m'interroge
aujourd'hui sur comment protéger les
épargnants les plus modestes
hier le gouverneur de la Banque de
France indiqué que que la hausse du
livret A donc qui est prévue à 2%
au 1er août n'étaient pas terminée ma
question est la suivante sur un temps
sur un temps long est-ce que vous ne
pensez pas que
l'idée d'indexer
d'indexer pardon le taux de rémunération
du Livret A sur l'inflation pour être
une piste de réflexion
où il y a un risque de
désavantager la consommation et donc ce
risque serait trop grand et le deuxième
qui est aussi un sujet qui a été évoqué
qui est sur la relation entre
l'inflation et le logement aujourd'hui
et notamment sur le prix du logement
pour les pour les locataires aujourd'hui
c'est un poste particulièrement élevé
dans le dans leur budget près 32% des
dépenses
des ménages locataires du parc privé
comme du public alors qu'en 2001 pour
rappel elle n'était que de
euh de 27%
pour l'Insee l'IRL l'indice de référence
des loyers a Bondy de près 2,5% pour le
premier trimestre 2022 ce qui est inédit
depuis 2008
c'est vrai que depuis 2008 la courbe de
l'indice de référence des loyers suit
avec retard la cour de l'indice des prix
à la consommation c'est vrai qu'avec
l'augmentation de l'inflation on voit
que inéluctablement les prochains
indices qui seront publiés au troisième
et quatrième trimestre seront donc
beaucoup plus élevés car on le constate
l'IRL a toujours du retard sur
l'inflation
Thierry dans le civet j'y viens donc
dans la loi sur le pouvoir d'achat
actuellement examiné à l'Assemblée le
gouvernement a refusé d'intégrer le gel
des loyers se contenant au plafonnement
de l'augmentation des loyers à 3,5% et
ce pendant un an afin de limiter
l'impact de l'inflation sur les
locataires en ma question est la
suivante dans la mesure où la formule
d'indexation des loyers actuels protège
pleinement
les propriétaires contre l'inflation au
détriment des locataires ne pensez-vous
pas qu'un gel de l'IRL serait pertinent
pour faire face à l'inflation des prix
des loyers merci merci Thierry Isabelle
briquet puis Christian BIAC
merci monsieur le Président merci au 4
intervenants de ce matin puisque
l'inflation n'est pas due à un trop de
circulation monétaire dans l'économie et
dans la mesure où la hausse des salaires
permettra à la fois aux françaises et
aux Français de mieux boucler leurs fins
de mois mais aussi de garantir le
fonctionnement de notre système de
solidarité la question est vraiment
d'importance ce matin il nous a été dit
que la marge d'évolution des salaires
était liée à la productivité des
entreprises comme cette productivité est
en baisse cela ne laisse guère envisager
une embellie au niveau un des salaires
pourtant certains économistes inversent
cette logique ce sont les hausses des
salaires qui permettent les gains de
productivité et sont même bénéfiques
pour pour l'emploi car plus de pouvoir
d'achat donc plus de dépenses et plus
d'activité économiques donc j'aimerais
bien avoir votre opinion sur cette
position là
merci merci Isabelle Christian BIAC puis
Vincent Seguin merci Monsieur Président
je vais essayer de d'être très bref
parce que c'est votre demande merci
d'abord à nos quatre intervenants qui
ont balayé toute cette problématique de
l'inflation du pouvoir d'achat je me
permettrai de retenir que la seule
certitude que vous partagez c'est le
nombre d'incertitudes qui planent sur
l'évolution
mais je retiens quand même ce cache
souligner monsieur plane chez cette
inflation ne concerne pas de manière
égale toute le territoire et je crains
qu'à nouveau ce soit cette franche
périphérique qui a provoqué le moment
des gilets jaunes et qui a provoqué un
vote extrême au moment des élections qui
soient à nouveau en première ligne
avaient des conséquences sociales et
politiques que nous devons pas négliger
au-delà des des aspects financiers il y
a aussi ça à voir
alors
l'énergie à une place prépondérante et
je n'ai pas solution miracle mais je
voudrais quand même mettre le doigt sur
quelque chose
j'avais hier le maire de cajou les
Béziers dans les routes téléphone il y a
un an et demi qu'il a lancé sur son
ancienne décharge un projet de par
photovoltaïque un an et demi
l'étude d'impact a été réalisé
et là il atteint la vis de la Commission
alors moi faire le par photovoltaïque de
casu elle ne va pas régler notre
problème énergétique mais combien y
a-t-il de cajoule des Béziers en France
combien y a-t-il de projets concernant
la tradition énergétique qui sont
bloqués qui sont bloqués parce que on
n'a pas compris qu'il y avait la guerre
à l'Ukraine qu'il y avait la menace de
la fermeture du robinet par voilà des
mir Poutine et on continuait à être le
dossier au rythme normal sans donner un
coup d'accélérateur donc ce n'est pas la
panacée mais c'est un outil qu'on a
disposition c'est d'accélérer cette
rayon dans une région éthique en mettant
le turbo sur les fonctions des dossiers
pour que tous ces projets qui sont
actuellement dans les tiroirs sortent
enfin voir le jour
je suis pas sûr que la question
s'adresse à des économistes mais en tout
cas à l'administration de manière
générale on va dire merci
Christian Vincent Segoin puis Jérôme
Bacher
oui merci monsieur le Président juste
une question sur sur l'inflation
vous nous avez pas parlé de de la Chine
avec la avec la politique du covid et
puis de la création de de pénurie qui
est volontaire plus ou moins pour
augmenter les prix je suis surpris aussi
que
vous ne parliez pas de du rôle de des
États-Unis aujourd'hui qui ont qui ont
ange engagé une politique d'augmentation
des salaires pour faire face inflation
et de l'effet de la parité euro-dollar
sur sur l'inflation que l'on va subir
vous nous avez parlé en échange
de l'augmentation des salaires qui a eu
lieu au cours de la dernière année
de l'épargne des ménages qui baissent de
et on a bien compris que c'était la
productivité des entreprises qui faisait
la zone tampon
pour compenser ce cette inflation
nous sommes et on l'a bien compris dans
vos propos très sensibles à la balance
commerciale qui est très négative donc
notre politique de désindustrialisation
de la France et aujourd'hui on en paye
les conséquences d'après ce que je
comprends et pour rétablir le rôle alors
moi je pensais que le rôle de la Banque
centrale des banques centrales sur
l'inflation avait un rôle prédominant
mais ce qui n'est pas forcément le cas
et ça ça m'inquiète donc maintenant le
rôle des États est-ce que c'est d'agir
plus sur le pouvoir d'achat des Français
ou est-ce qu'ils doivent plus intervenir
comme l'Allemagne a pu le faire sur le
travail de l'emploi et la diminution des
charges pour faire face aux zones de
turbulences
merci Vincent Jérôme bachel puis
Sébastien me rend
oui merci monsieur le Président moi je
crois que Eric channel que on en sera
effectivement
en récession à la fin de l'année je lui
ai dit un trimestre je le redis ici nous
serons en récession en fin d'année donc
il faut déjà s'y préparer historiquement
l'inflation s'arrête quand il y a un
choc d'inflation comme celui-ci par une
récession et c'est comme ça que les prix
reviennent un peu à la normale s'il y a
des historiens ils pourront me
contredire volontiers mais j'ai juste
une question un peu paradoxale j'ai bien
entendu qu'il y avait des chocs d'offres
et enfin des négatif
ce qui augmente les prix et donc tout ce
dont nous parle c'est des mesures de
demande la mesure de pouvoir d'achat il
me semble que ce sont des mesures de
demande et donc je suis un peu
à rebours de mes camarades en me disant
mais qu'est-ce qu'on est en train de
faire on est en train de faire des
mesures de demande comme les États-Unis
l'ont fait
il y a quelques temps il y avait pas de
problème de demande on a relancé de
plusieurs centaines de milliards de
dollars par Monsieur Biden effectivement
il y a eu un choc d'inflation aux
États-Unis est-ce qu'on n'est pas en
train de finalement de d'entretenir la
machine
merci cher Jérôme pour votre optimisme
Sébastien Meurant merci à nos
intervenants
il y a eu un choc sur l'énergie avec la
découverte de tout ce qui était gaz de
schiste pétrole de chiche exploitation
aux États-Unis il y a eu un gouvernement
et là on a eu on a un choc d'offre
inverse
mais aussi on a quand même une politique
monétaire qui était en Europe
ultra expansive et qui a créé évidemment
un discordance entre l'offre de monnaie
la production et là cet aspect des
choses
relativement aux autres monnaies
la part de la baisse de la valeur de
l'euro par rapport au dollar par rapport
aux Francs suisses par rapport aux
autres monnaies aussi génère un choc
d'inflation lié à tout ce qui est tout
ce qui est importé et il échappé à
personne que l'Europe est un des rares
continents assez dépourvu en énergie et
je viens de dire Jérôme c'est pas c'est
pas c'est pas d'aujourd'hui et quelle
est la part justement de
d'affaiblissement de la monnaie dans le
rôle de l'inflation importée et de la
baisse du pouvoir d'achat des Français
merci comme il y en a pas assez moi j'en
avais deux de plus une
[Musique]
une pour Monsieur Ferrand qui nous a
présenté une consommation de surépargne
estimée à 43% dans en un seul semestre
donc je crois comprendre que quand on
est sur de tels chiffres ce sont les
gens qui étaient finalement avec les
plus petites sur épargne d'une certaine
façon qui les ont utilisés parce que moi
je pense que ceux qui ont des énormes
sur épargne et ils n'ont pas pour autant
les consommer enfin pour partir mais
est-ce qu'il y a une estimation est-ce
que ça pourrait vouloir dire que je suis
pas 80% de l'assurépanne serait consommé
la fin de l'année quelque chose comme ça
donc est-ce que vous avez une petite
idée peut-être madame Benassi également
sur cette question là de est-ce que
finalement l'assurait pas ne va pas
disparaître aussi vite qu'elle est
apparue quoi bon en dehors des impôts de
20% pour les plus riches qui ne la
consommera pas parce que voilà il y a
pas de besoin particulier
et la deuxième question qui était qui
était intéressante là je peux qu'il a
dit ça mais du bon sens mais à part que
je l'avais je n'ai pas fait ce lien sur
l'idée que si on arrête les aides au
carburant sur l'électricité le soutien
etc du coup on aurait finalement une
inflation qui serait supérieure à la
moyenne européenne par effet de rebond
si Jupiler et alors c'est marrant je
veux pas du tout vu ça c'est sous les
radars mais est-ce que le gouvernement
doit se préparer à dire qu'il fait moins
bien que les autres finalement bon allez
on y va monsieur Chanet alors vous avez
5 minutes monsieur Chanet ce coup-ci
comptez de manière
juste donc
je traduis monsieur le Président ne
répondez surtout pas à toutes les
questions d'ailleurs je ne le peux pas
bon en ce qui me concerne il y avait
beaucoup de questions très techniques
destinées à de différent Agnès Benassi
ou à Mathieu plane je vais
je veux en prendre je vais en prendre
d'autres d'abord la question des
difficultés de recrutement va me
permettre d'insister sur le côté choctov
en vous parlant de l'enquête
trimestrielle de l'Insee qui est très
ancienne elle date des années 70 depuis
1990 elle pose aussi une question sur
les difficultés de recrutement et
lorsqu'on regarde les résultats de cette
enquête depuis 1970 donc là je vous
parle vraiment de longue période il y a
deux
pourcentages de répondant qui font
crever tous les plafonds c'est celui sur
l'incapacité à produire plus en raison
de difficultés de goulots de production
et ceci par exemple la pénurie de
semi-conducteur en fait partie c'est un
groupe de production qui est en amont
pour les entreprises on n'a jamais été
aussi haut en terme d'écart type on est
un petit peu dans ce que ce dont deux
différents parlait mais c'est quand même
très frappant que c'est le plus haut
historiquement et pour les difficultés
de recrutement ou la question n'est
posée que depuis 1990 on n'a jamais été
aussi haut donc nous avons bien à faire
en France je parle pas d'une enquête
faite aux États-Unis à un choc d'offres
dans la dans le sens où les entreprises
alors il s'agit surtout du secteur
industriel mais c'est important pour
l'inflation parce qu'elle est beaucoup
concentrée sur les biens ne peuvent pas
produire plus et donc le paradoxe dont
vous parlez monsieur sénateur de
stimuler la demande alors que c'est
l'offre qui est contrainte et il est
évident alors ma réponse a quand même à
votre question c'est que ça a un sens ça
un sens si ça permet de limiter les
enchaînements inflationnistes suivants
donc des politiques dont le but ne
serait pas de stimuler la demande ce qui
est absurde quand on a un choc d'offre
mais de faire en sorte que les
enchaînements salariaux soient modérés
est une politique que je trouve
pertinente parce qu'elle pense moyen
long terme
des pistes trouvent qu'elle répond aussi
mais ça c'est une question qui est
beaucoup plus politique à des impératifs
politiques de court terme donc il y a
quand même un certain sens à faire cette
chose absurde qui consiste à soutenir la
demande à condition que ce soit
premièrement temporaire deuxièmement que
sa vise à réduire les enchaînements
salariaux ce qui me fait répondre à la
question comment est-ce qu'on finance
les baisses de charge par le déficit
budgétaire il y a pas d'autres moyens
mais je répète le point crucial c'est
temporaire on voit bien la difficulté
politique c'est quand on fait quelque
chose de temporaire tout le monde
voudrait ensuite que ce soit permanent
deuxième point sur lequel il faut
vraiment insister c'est la situation
extraordinairement difficile de l'Italie
je pense que c'est quelque chose qui
s'annonce mal pour l'ensemble de la zone
euro c'est un cauchemar pour l'Italie
avant tout mais aussi pour la Banque
centrale européenne en plus du fait que
la croissance en Italie est nulle depuis
très longtemps donc quand on se plaint
des gains de productivité en France
c'est une affaire qui est très ancienne
en Italie et c'est la raison principal
pour laquelle les marchés sont inquiets
politiques budgétaire italienne elle a
toujours été restrictive elle a pas
toujours bien entendu mais les
réceptives depuis très longtemps mais
quand il y a pas de croissance on peut
se poser la question comment aller
rembourse allez vous rembourser votre
dette d'ailleurs c'est la BCE qui achète
votre dette d'habitude donc l'Italie est
dans une situation fragile ancienne mais
ce conjugue le choc covid qui touche
quand même et d'une manière
particulièrement importante de
l'industrie touristique qui est
importante pour l'Italie et deuxièmement
le choc énergétique excusez moi du peu
ça nous fait trois chocs pour l'Italie
et donc les réponses que l'ABC va nous
donner aujourd'hui sur son outil anti
fragmentation sont importants mais je
pense qu'il faut se dire d'avance qu'il
y a que le risque italien a augmenté
avec ses crises alors l'Italie bénéficie
de transfert l'Union européenne ça
pourrait ne pas être suffisant ça doit
être sur nos radars troisième sujet
est-ce qu'il faut mobiliser l'épargne
excédentaire dont Denis différents nous
a expliqué qu'elle était déjà 40 ou 50%
rogné par l'inflation mais ça en quand
même 50% qui reste alors moi je dirais
que si c'est la mobiliser pour ça il y a
la consommation il faut pas le faire
puisque on a une contrainte d'offre donc
pousser les gens à plus consommer
aujourd'hui ça fait de l'inflation plus
qu'autre chose en revanche fait en sorte
que cette épargne puisse aller vers des
investissements donc c'est une autre
manière de soutenir l'économie ce n'est
pas l'enchaînement habituel pouvoir
d'achat consommation emploi non pas du
tout si ça va vers de l'investissement
et que cet investissement permet
d'augmenter l'offre à long terme de
choses dont nous manquons comme
l'énergie des carbonées et ben c'est
évidemment une chose qui me paraît très
intelligente heureux de l'art et
politique monétaire américaine alors ça
c'est assez crucial la politique
monétaire américaine a été en retard sur
l'évolution de l'inflation aux
États-Unis qui je le rappelle avait
commencé par une accélération des coûts
salariaux avant la crise covid donc
c'était déjà une économie au plein
emploi on commence à avoir accéléré la
fête est restée si je puis dire un petit
peu de côté jusqu'à que les chiffres
d'inflation et qu'elle soit assez
généralisée aux États-Unis il est obligé
à réagir Ben bernanchi a reconnu même
s'il n'en fait plus partie des solidaire
que bah oui on a été trop loin à réagir
et donc on va pas se plaindre du fait
que la Fed réagisse contre l'inflation
américaine je rappelle que l'inflation
c'est mondiale et que si on a de
l'inflation aux États-Unis on a
l'inflation partout alors évidemment il
y a un jeu non coopératif par définition
des politiques monétaires en relevant
cette taux d'intérêt la fête contribue à
faire monter le dollar dont la
principale raison pour laquelle il monte
c'est l'augmentation du prix du pétrole
ce n'est pas la politique monétaire
lorsque le prix du pétrole augmente il y
a un recyclage des pétrodollars moins
importantes dans les années 70 qui va
vers des actifs américains donc plus de
demandes de dollars et en plus ce qui
fait une grande différence avec les
années 70 les États-Unis maintenant sont
exportateurs nets d'énergie en
particulier grâce au gaz de schiste donc
ces deux facteurs expliquent l'essentiel
de la hausse du dollar vient ajouter la
politique monétaire donc de mon point de
vue c'est pas tant l'euro qui est faible
c'est un dollar qui est hyper fort
contre toute monnaie alors je signale en
passant on en a pas parlé mais que ceci
pose un grave problème pour le crédit
d'un grand nombre de pays émergents les
spreads de crédit dont je parlais pour
les entreprises sont en train de
s'écarter de manière très importante
pour des pays qui dépendent beaucoup de
la politique monétaire américaine mais
qui ne sont pas directement concernés
par les décisions la fête ne prend pas
ses décisions pour la zone dollars donc
nous sommes si je puis dire dans la zone
euro victime collatérale la seule
manière
qui pourrait
compenser en partie cette politique
monétaire américaine ça serait d'avoir
une politique monétaire équivalente mais
on a tous compris je viens de rappeler
la situation italienne que les les
dégâts seraient encore pire que
l'avantage qu'il y aurait avoir une
monnaie plus forte donc je pense que
ceux-ci doit se doit l'accepter si il y
a récession les mécanismes sur le dollar
s'inversent les anticipations sur le
taux d'intérêt s'inverse le prix du
pétrole baisse donc le dollar baisse
donc ne nous préoccupons pas trop de
cette baisse de l'euro par rapport au
dollar c'est quelque chose qui est
transitoire
j'en reste là monsieur le Président bien
et vous avez fixé la maille pour les
autres dans Matthieu plane va bénéficier
de 7 minutes 7 minutes ah oui ok
beaucoup beaucoup de questions donc
c'est merci en tout cas ça soulève quand
même pas mal d'interrogations et on va
essayer d'apporter quelques réponses
en quelques minutes sur le shutdov
négatif je partage en partie en fait le
diagnostic parce qu'il y a deux chocs
d'offres en fait dans dans cette affaire
il y a quand même un choc d'offre sur
les matières premières qui est pas le
même que sur les produits industriels or
ça a pas les mêmes effets y compris sur
notre balance commerciale et les
réponses qu'on peut donner à ce choc
d'Off négatif dans un cas on voit bien
qu'on a un problème de politique
industrielle avec les approvisionnements
enfin qu'on va pas régler du jour au
lendemain mais qu'on connaît depuis un
certain temps avec les défis de
commerciaux qu'on a évoqué donc ça pose
la question
de comment être plus performant d'un
point de vue industriel
et quels sont les politiques à mener
dans l'autre cas le choc d'offre négatif
lié à au fait que la Russie
progressivement écartée du marché
mondial des hydrocarbures posent
beaucoup de questions et les effets
notamment sur la demande sachant que
bien sûr on va pas produire ces
hydrocarbures et que même substituer ces
hydrocarbures par d'autres types
d'énergie qui sont non fossiles posent
beaucoup de questions et c'est des
enjeux de moyens long terme
donc ça pose d'abord la question de
comment on répond à ce choc sur
l'énergie quel est son impact sur les
ménages et sur les entreprises et
comment on essaye d'accélérer j'allais
dire peut-être le point positif de cette
crise c'est peut-être d'accélérer la
transition en tout cas elle serait de
trouver des solutions pour avoir une un
mix énergétique plus décarbonée et
éventuellement trouver des voies vers
une consommation on va dire un peu plus
efficace
mais dans le court terme je sais que
l'énergie est assez peu substituable
même si vous faites un peu de sobriété
si vous essayez de d'instruire un peu de
télétravail ou de covoiturage
pour beaucoup et on l'a dit le problème
c'est que c'est un choc aussi assez
différent selon les types de ménage
entre le cadre parisien dans un
appartement effectivement la classe
moyenne en zone rurale qui a de
véhicules avec un logement peut-être
assez mal isolé le choc est n'a rien à
voir donc le problème c'est que c'est
aussi la difficulté d'accompagner le
changement et l'impact à court terme
social quoi c'est à dire on voit que si
un bien est peu substituable c'est
directement le reste à vivre qui diminue
et là vous êtes aussi face à autre chose
c'est comment on répartit en fait ce
choc inflationniste c'est-à-dire qui
prend en charge le choc impressionniste
l'État en fait en réalité a fait
relativement beaucoup j'allais dire par
rapport à ce qu'on a vu ailleurs c'est
pour ça que ça coûte cher et que ça a
été possible et dans un premier temps
la question maintenant c'est dire si le
choc finalement est pas transitoire on
peut pas maintenir des dispositifs aussi
larges et donc il faut les cibler et on
voit que plus on va aller dans le détail
et plus on va essayer de cibler plus
c'est délicat et plus ça va faire des
performances et vous les essayez de
garder un signal prix c'est-à-dire dire
en sorte il y a pas forcément de raison
de mettre un prix de l'énergie à un
niveau bas alors qui coule le niveau du
prix mondial est très élevé ou alors ça
coûte très cher donc c'est où est-ce que
vous faites ce ciblage or c'est vrai que
j'ai l'impression que le ciblage il va
être relativement bas il va couvrir on
va dire au SMIC voir un peu au dessus
donc ça va poser toute la question
j'allais dire des personnes qui sont
allés à 1,2,3,5
dont et ça l'état n'y peut rien mais on
voit bien que la réponse aussi des
employeurs peut être très différente sur
le salaire c'est à dire on a des
élasticités nous c'est un demi enfin en
gros c'est 0,5 c'est à dire que quand
l'inflation augmente comme ça de 1% les
salaires augmentent de 0,5 en fait dans
un premier temps mais la situation peut
être très différente selon les
situations individuelles et donc
certaines entreprises vont démarche de
manœuvre pour augmenter les salaires
et d'autres beaucoup moins ce qui est
pas le cas par exemple des retraités qui
vont voir assez logiquement leur
retraite augmentée ou les personnes au
SMIC ont une garantie de pouvoir d'achat
donc la question qui va être
fondamentale c'est pour les personnes
qui sont en emploi qui sont au-dessus du
SMIC principalement et dont l'employeur
qui sont dans des PME n'ont pas
forcément les marges de manœuvre pour
les augmenter et cela il passe en fait à
travers les mailles du filet j'ai
l'impression et ça ça va être assez
difficile d'expliquer que
ils se sont un peu les perdants de cette
crise là donc voilà donc je dis pas que
j'ai pas de réponse très claire là
dessus mais ça ça pose vraiment cette
question de ce choc d'offres et comment
on essaie d'accompagner ce choc d'offre
aussi d'un point de vue social parce que
c'est un des impacts sur le point
d'achat
surtout autre point l'épargne accumulée
elle est considérable on parle de 170
milliards depuis le début de la crise
mais forcément c'est pareil elle est pas
accumulée de la même façon en gros 80%
de cette épargne et détenus par les 25%
des ménages en haut de l'échelle des
revenus ce qui est assez logique on
regarde des choses donc c'est vrai que
c'est pareil si vous cumulez le choc
macroéconomique et c'est chacun
individuels on a des choses très très
différentes c'est à dire entre des
ménages quand il met de l'épargne qui
sont moins exposés à ce choc et qui ont
des capacités de réagir et ceux qui ont
déjà mangé leur épargne et qui se
retrouvent avec un choc très négatif
donc j'allais dire le problème c'est
qu'on a un choc macroéconomique et donc
on parle de risque de récession
moi je serais un peu moins dur enfin je
pense que bien sûr que le réseau et
session est évident mais je pense qu'il
dépendent beaucoup ce qui va se passer
dans les mois à venir avec la avec la
Russie l'approvisionnement du gaz russe
qui sera mon avis assez déterminant mais
on a aussi un choc microéconomique et
c'est là la difficulté des pouvoirs
publics c'est comment vous répondez à
des chocs micro pour les entreprises
pour les ménages vous avez pas faire de
vous avez pas traité 30 millions de cas
et donc forcément vous allez avoir des
effets de seuil vous allez avoir des des
problèmes et en même temps vous avez une
question budgétaire il faut être
raisonnable aussi c'est-à-dire qu'on
voit bien qu'on a déjà eu un choc covid
qui a été massif on a près 200 milliards
d'euros de d'impulsion budgétaire qui
ont été mis
et donc on peut pas continuer
indéfiniment comme ça ou à un moment
donné va se poser la question du
financement surtout avec la remontée des
taux dont on a parlé
si les taux remontent et que notre
croissance diminue ça va poser quelques
difficultés donc une récession ça pose
ou si ces difficultés là c'est que une
récession c'est aussi moins de recettes
fiscale donc vous êtes face à ce
problème et
du coup
bon je termine peut-être là dessus
un point important aussi et c'est pour
ça je peux pas envoyer trop de signaux
négatifs mais
quelque part j'allais dire nous enfin en
tant que Macron économiste on a une une
interrogation forte c'est comment ça se
fait qu'on crée autant d'emploi et c'est
plutôt une bonne chose pour le marché du
travail mais on reconnaît il y a
toujours le revers de la médaille c'est
que le regard de la médaille c'est que
la productivité a baissé depuis 2019 ce
qui est aussi historique c'est-à-dire
que pour produire la même chose on a
besoin de plus d'emplois vous regardez
la valeur ajoutée aujourd'hui du secteur
privé le même niveau que la valeur
ajoutée de fin 2019 donc on réalise la
même valeur ajoutée d'un point de vue
macronique on a 700 000 emplois en plus
donc 3% d'emplois en plus on a besoin de
3% d'emploi en plus pour produire la
même chose ce qui pose la question
effectivement des marges de manœuvre y
compris des entreprises pour augmenter
les salaires dans ce cadre là c'est à
dire que soit il y a un peu de
croissance elles vont faire de la
productivité mais elles vont détruire
des emplois
soit ils augmentent les salaires dans ce
cadre là et ça va poser beaucoup de
questions sur leurs compétitivité donc
c'est vrai que l'équation est
malheureusement assez assez dur surtout
dans un monde où on va devoir accélérer
la transition ou une inflation qui peut
être un peu plus robuste le problème des
déficits et un ralentissement de la
croissance donc les enjeux j'allais dire
je crois que devant nous et je veux bien
croire que c'est en partie vrai
ça nous aide tout ça merci Mathieu plane
d'avoir dit votre absence de solution
Denis on va demander de faire un pardon
et oui on va vous remettre à votre place
madame vous allez conclure traditionnel
additionnellement nous laissons plutôt
la direction du Trésor conclure vous
voyez ce président juste avant si vous
voulez un mot sur la productivité c'est
vous aurez tout inventé monsieur alors
allons-y à titre exceptionnel
c'est pour mettre un bémol à ce constat
qui a été fait par Madame Benassi et par
Monsieur plaindre de la baisse de la
productivité en tout cas de son fort
ralentissement
une des raisons quand même très
importantes et une très bonne raison
c'est que les réformes du marché du
travail font que aujourd'hui sont
employés en France quand des gens qui
ont une plus faible productivité que le
pool de ceux qui étaient employé
auparavant
si on fait des réformes du marché du
travail je me félicite qu'elles aient
réussi on a réussi à faire baisser le
taux de chômage à 7% de provocation pas
de provocation ça fait inévitablement
baisser la productivité avant ces
réformes du marché du travail je disais
aux gens qui me posaient des questions
je saurai si ça marche si la
productivité baisse donc ce n'est pas en
soi une mauvaise nouvelle la
productivité
structurelle c'est beaucoup plus
important et ça c'est une question
d'innovation est-ce que nous innovons
assez en France je crains que non mais
cet effet de productivité qui tient à la
composition de la ce travail on va quand
même pas le regretter ne pas regretter
que des gens puissent travailler
aujourd'hui en France alors
qu'auparavant ils ne pouvait pas
travailler
je préfère la conclusion alors de
différent pour pour compléter sur ce
point parce qu'effectivement ça faisait
partie des éléments que je voulais
évoquer revenir sur l'enjeu de
productivité qui est vraiment
déterminant sur les évolutions des
salaires je crois plus à la termination
de la productivité vers les salaires que
des salaires vers la productivité donc
la théorie du salaire déficience je
crois quand même plus que celle la
productivité qui qui détermine dans un
premier temps les salaires sur la
productivité il y a aussi un élément qui
est alors je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec l'observation qui vient de faire
Eric il faut regarder que sur les taux
d'emploi qui ont le plus bougé récemment
c'est le taux d'emploi des plus jeunes
et ça c'est l'impact notamment des
politiques de développement de de
l'apprentissage de l'alternance on a 4,5
points de taux d'emploi en plus pour les
pour les 16 24 ans par rapport à la
situation de 2019 et il y a aucun autre
pays européen qui a le plus augmenté ce
retour dans le plan des 15 24 sur la
période récente et ça c'est un effet de
composition sur la productivité deuxième
élément de composition qui est tout à
fait remarquable sur intéressante pour
expliquer leur ralentissement de la
productivité ce sont les pratiques de
rétention de main d'oeuvre dans les dans
les entreprises et en particulier dans
l'industrie depuis 2019 la productivité
de l'industrie est négative alors que
c'est le secteur combien même on sait
que l'industrie a un poids dans le PIB
qui est quand même assez faible en
France relativement à la zone euro c'est
une litote que de le dire et bien la
Russie est grosso modo elle produit
entre 40 et 50% des gains de
productivité de l'ensemble de l'économie
or depuis trois ans la productivité
enfin la valeur ajoutée à moins
progresser que ne la fait l'emploi dans
l'industrie donc la productivité a
reculé et là c'est vraiment les
politiques de rétention de main d'oeuvre
je sais que j'ai des difficultés de
recrutement très aiguë et bien
au premier retournement conjoncturel
venu je vais essayer de préserver le
plus longtemps possible mais salariés en
place parce que je sais que j'aurais du
mal à les retrouver au moment du
redémarrage de l'activité et ça c'est
vrai que c'est un des effets assez fort
de la des difficultés de recrutement je
vais passer en revue quelques quelques
points effectivement sur la surépanne
cela a été évoqué par par Mathieu à
l'instant je crois que c'est dès le mois
de mars que le avait dit que en gros
l'assurépanne des deux premiers défis
l'avait été lessivé donc alors
maintenant je ne sais plus jusqu'où
c'est en train de remonter mais
probablement qu'on aurait peut-être pas
loin du 5/6 désormais dans la dans la
surépargne aura disparu mais je n'ai
aucun élément pour la c'est juste un
jugement
c'est juste un sentiment bien plus
qu'autre chose sur le caractère durable
de l'inflation effectivement je ne suis
pas prononcé là-dessus il y a un point
ça a été évoqué par par Éric c'est que
et ça a été repris aussi par plusieurs
d'entre vous on n'avait pas parlé dans
nos présentations du Tour de change
parce que le taux de change en fait
vient de donner une deuxième étape
peut-être à l'inflation importée c'est à
dire que l'inflation importée est
présidée est un venait principalement
des cours des matières premières et
effectivement les matières premières
reculent en ce moment et c'est très fort
sur sur les métaux c'est aussi une bonne
illustration de ce que il y a un risque
d'inflation de récession qui est
croissant devant nous mais désormais
l'inflation importée ne peut peut-être
changer de nature dans le sens où elle
proviendra un peu plus du comportement
de l'euro contre le dollar quand bien
même je suis d'accord on le voit pas ce
dégrader encore bien enfin se dépression
encore bien plus longtemps parce que les
écarts de taux d'intérêt vont
progressivement se resserrer sur le sur
le revenu disponible brut en fait le
graphique que j'avais montré que vous
aviez sur lequel vous êtes revenus
monsieur le sénateur c'était un
graphique sur qui essaye de réconcilier
le message des économistes les
économistes en gros ils disent même il y
a pas de problème de pouvoir d'achat
pris à l'échelle macroéconomique et
c'est vrai qu'on a une progression sur
10 ans de 10% de pouvoir d'achat durant
les disponible oui alors c'est peut-être
pas assez je sais pas mais ça c'est une
affaire de d'appréciation mais quand on
le regarde ensuite au niveau du ressenti
le ressenti il a exprimé par un ménage
or quand le quand on va corriger le
revenu disponible par la composante
démographique par la composante
également sociologique il faut se
rappeler que le nombre de ménages
progresse deux fois plus vite que ne le
fait la population alors on se rend
compte qu'il n'y a pas de progression du
pouvoir d'achat et pas seulement sur les
trois dernières années mais également
depuis 2010 donc il y a bien il y a bien
une mesure par qui est utilisée par les
économistes qui dit bah oui il y a du
pouvoir d'achat qui est distribué mais
le ressenti individuel du fait de ses
évolutions démographiques et
sociologique n'est pas n'est pas au
rendez-vous donc j'essayais de
réconcilier les les deux appréciations
sur sur l'aspect des minima sociaux qui
étaient évoqués par par Didier Rambaud
je ne sais pas combien de salariés sont
concernés je crois que c'est assez peu
il y a très peu de salariés qui se
trouvent au minima de branches et
surtout bah quand il passe en dessous du
SMIC parce que de toute façon c'est la
règle du SMIC qui va s'imposer alors sur
les il y a pas de de mécanisme
automatiques qui induisent dès lors
qu'il y a dès lors que le SMIC dépasse
le minima sociaux il y a pas de
mécanisme automatique qui fait une
renégociation de la part des dans les
branches tout se passe dans le cadre des
NAO des négociations annuelles
obligatoires qui en général américaine
plutôt en fin d'exercice ou au début
d'exercice et qui était en fait calé sur
de facto sur le rythme d'évolution du
SMIC là on est sur une sur une période
qui est très particulière qui tient ce
qu'il y a des des relèvements du SMIC
qui interviennent en cours d'année et
donc la plupart beaucoup de branches
ayant mis en place des clauses de
revoyure en cours d'année on va avoir
des renégociations qui vont se faire
mais la proportion de personnes
concernées est relativement faible alors
après le nombre de smicards c'est je
crois aux environs de 12% des salariés
et toute la question de savoir comment
va se déplacer la hausse du SMIC vers
les personnes qui sont situées un peu au
dessus du SMIC est-ce qu'on va avoir une
augmentation très importante de la
proportion de smicard en proportion des
salariés c'est là le point qui me semble
être assez important à regarder et puis
sur le sur la mobilisation de la
surépanne qui reste parce qu'il en
restera effectivement
ça doit être mis effectivement au regard
des enjeux d'investissement nous bon et
en particulier d'investissement dans la
transition énergétique nous avons essayé
d'estimer avec ces codes le montant
d'investissement qu'il faudrait faire
pour simplement se mettre sur la
trajectoire du du 01net enfin du net 0
pardon en 2050 il nous manque en gros
entre 40 et 70 milliards
d'investissements par an donc ça veut
bien dire qu'il y a un enjeu de
mobilisation de toutes les ressources
financières dont on peut disposer pour
les fléchies vers l'investissement donc
la mobilisation de cet de cette sure
épargne à destination de
l'investissement nous semble tout à fait
fondamental pour tenir les objectifs que
l'on sait assigner dans le cadre de la
réduction nous avions appelé à la
formation de fonds de garantie de fonds
de capital garanties c'est pour à
destination de l'épargne moyenne c'est
toujours une mesure que l'on porte parce
que elle sera vraiment fléchée sur sur
l'investissement alors je n'ai pas le
temps de répondre à tous les aspects
j'insister effectivement sur l'aspect
italien il y a quand même une inquiétude
assez forte à voir sur l'Italie d'autant
que c'est substituts en termes de
mobilisation d'énergie que sont
notamment l'hydroélectrique bien il se
trouve aussi un peu complexifié dans une
période de d'absence d'eau et de fortes
sécheresses que connaît l'Italie c'est
aussi une circonstance qui va être très
importante qui fait un déséquilibre
énergétique
c'était juste pour rajouter un petit peu
plus dans le noir oui ou si vous nous
avez pas mais personne ne nous a rassuré
sur quoi que ce soit donc c'est pas tout
à fait l'objet de cette
réunion aujourd'hui mais vous avez dit
la surépargne même si on la mettait sur
les objectifs
en termes donc de transition énergétique
par exemple ou écologique de manière
plus large ça serait une année quoi une
année d'investissement ça résout pas
tout quoi bon tout à fait très bien
bon ben c'est à vous madame Benassi kere
alors donc traditionnellement on laisse
conclure si je puis dire
un interlocuteur avec lequel nous sommes
forcément en discussion dans le cadre
des projets qui nous viennent et puis
vous allez avoir une responsabilité
supplémentaire c'est de bien vérifier
que tous nos collègues ont eu une
réponse et donc si par hasard il y avait
quelques trous ils sont pour vous et
sinon il y aura une petite bronca à la
fin vous verrez c'est très sympathique
madame médecin
je répondrai avec plaisir à la plupart
des questions vous m'arrêterez quand
leur sonnera
d'abord pour j'étais d'accord avec
presque tout ce que disait mes collègues
je voulais insister peut-être sur
l'aspect
stabilisateur de la conjoncture mondiale
c'est-à-dire que effectivement c'est la
conjoncture ralentie c'est la croissance
ralentie à cause de ce choc d'offre et
ben c'est stabilisant et en particulier
je voulais donner un petit ordre de
grandeur sur le pétrole parce que le
pétrole russe à peu près 4 le pétrole
russe envoyé en Europe donc qui est
soumis à l'embargo c'est à peu près 4%
de l'offre mondiale c'est un marché
mondial et on voit bien que si la
croissance mondiale ralenti de un point
et bien un quart de ce choc qui est
absorbé si on pense que 1% de croissance
en moi c'est 1% demande de pétrole en
moins grosso modo c'est ça et donc ça va
assez vite en fait parce que ça a marché
mondial c'est pas la même chose pour le
gaz qui est un marché local
j'étais moins d'accord bon d'abord je
suis à la conjoncture tous les
indicateurs sont pas catastrophiques il
y a encore des motifs d'espoir et en
particulier les conditions financières
bon éric a insisté sur les spreads mais
le crédit ne ralentit pas il est encore
très digne on pourrait s'en inquiéter
mais
il est il y a encore du soutien il y a
encore du soutien et et les climats tout
n'est pas négatif enfin nous on n'a pas
une lecture complètement sombre de la de
la conjoncture même si ça se dégrade
c'est c'est certain et alors sur la
mesure baisse temporaire des charges là
par contre j'ai un petit
différence de d'appréciation je pense
que il y a la théorie de l'incidence ça
nous dit que sur les hauts salaires bah
ça va augmenter les salaires des gens
qui ont déjà l'assuré pas mieux déjà et
donc ça ça ne va en rien à mon avis à
résoudre le problème de l'inflation ni
les problèmes peut-être un peu les
problèmes de recrutement des des haut
potentiel ça c'est vrai mais et le fait
que ce soit temporaire c'est quand même
très difficile et donc c'est pour ça
qu'on est quand même un peu circonspect
par rapport à d'autres pays qui ont
choisi de baisser la fiscalité des
charges etc on sait temporaire en France
les mesures temporaires ont tendance à
durer
et c'est extrêmement coûteux donc c'est
une manière enfin très coûteuse alors
donc du coup j'en viens à au point
central qui est donc c'est un chien au
terme de l'échange une partie de ce
qu'on produit va partir vers le reste du
monde même s'il revient éventuellement
sous forme de recyclage et donc les
Petro dollars Petro Europe peuvent
financer une partie de notre transition
et énergétique ce qui serait quand même
intéressant
mais il y a enfin c'est une perte pour
le pays donc ça doit se répartir entre
baisse de pouvoir d'achat pour les
ménages on est agrégé je parle pas
baisse des marges pour les entreprises
et le reste c'est pour le contribuable
et le contribuable c'est de nouveau des
ménages et des entreprises donc enfin on
a beau on dit on reporte sur l'état mais
en fait une fine et l'État c'est c'est
encore nous donc je pense qu'il faut
vraiment qu'on prenne conscience de ça
et là la boucle le prix salaire c'est
une sorte de lutte entre les
travailleurs et les entreprises pour ne
pas supporter la perte et en fait le
fait qu'à chaque tour on récupère on
récupère cute à 100%, ça accélère la
boucle presse salaire donc il est urgent
de la ralentir en et ben en faisant
supporter une partie de la charge à ceux
qui peuvent donc soit qu'ils sont
accumulés de l'épargne soit qu'ils ont
accumulé des marges pour répartir cette
perte et que ce pas que le contribuable
qui va la supporter éventuellement de
manière très inéquitable
donc et là je voudrais faire vraiment la
différence par rapport au prix de
l'énergie des carbonée si on avait un
choc de prix de l'énergie bicarbonée si
l'énergie est carbonée est aussi cher
que l'énergie fossile c'est pas du tout
pareil parce que ça reste dans le pays
et donc on a des entreprises qui
produisent de l'énergie des carbonée à
un prix élevé et cette prix élevé
éventuellement on va répartir une rampe
ou je ne sais pas mais ça reste dans le
pays c'est complètement différent comme
analyse
d'où l'importance de la transition
écologique et d'y mettre vraiment les
moyens alors est-ce que l'inflation va
être durable donc
pour 2022 le gouvernement prévoit en
moyenne annuelle une inflation de 5%
rappelez-vous qu'au début de l'année
c'était largement inférieur à ce qu'on
voit aujourd'hui
c'est à peu près dans la moyenne des
autres prévisionnistes attention c'est
au sens de l'Insee le quand on fait des
comparaisons internationales on prend la
Banque de France et donc c'est la façon
harmonisée qui est un peu supérieur
notamment en ce moment où il y a
beaucoup d'inflation énergétiques donc
tout ça est alors on peut tous se
tromper c'est c'est tout à fait possible
2023 il n'y a pas encore de prévisions
officielle mais on s'attend quand même à
un reflux de l'inflation avec une
changement de composition qui a déjà été
mentionné avec plus d'inflation interne
sous-jacentes et moins d'inflation
énergétique ne serait-ce que par un
effet de base
et par contre il faut distinguer le
niveau qui peut être permanent donc on
aurait une hausse permanente du d'une
coût de l'énergie et puis une inflation
qui elle serait qui régresserait de
manière graduelle et donc ça pose en
effet la question de la fin des
boucliers puisque si on a une marge
d'escalier même si ça cesse d'augmenter
on a une marge d'escalier et bah il va
falloir que progressivement le prix du
gaz le prix d'électricité
rattrape la marche que on a raté d'une
certaine manière volontairement
et ça ça fait effectivement de
l'inflation peut-être plus bas c'est
plus durable mais en fait et quand on
discute avec les gens de la BCE ils sont
d'accord avec ça ça peut infiner amener
un niveau de prix plus bas que s'il y
avait eu une inflation très forte
pendant une période plus courte parce
que ça ça maintient des anticipations
relativement ancrées et ça ça maintient
une boucle priscillaire enfin disons
contrôler donc et c'est en effet le
niveau final qui compte pour la
compétitivité alors laquelle réaction
budgétaire je pense que quand même on
est assez d'accord sur le fait que un
plan de relance général c'est pas la
chose à faire quand on a un choc d'offre
ce qu'il faut c'est préserver en effet
l'offre et l'offre d'énergie en
particulier et les ménages modestes d'où
l'idée de plus cibler le soutien
budgétaire que ce qui est le cas
aujourd'hui il a fallu un peu dans
l'urgence mettre en place des choses
générales parce que faire des choses
intelligentes ça prend du temps et comme
vous avez vu les cibler c'est compliqué
on a des tensions de on a donc des
tensions de recrutement qui amènent plus
qu'à une haute générale des salaires qui
en est au général des salaires ça va
faire plus de demandes donc ça résout
pas vraiment notre problème les tensions
elles sont particulièrement dans
certains secteurs donc on peut avoir des
os de salaires qui vont débloquer de
l'offre parce que on a de l'offre de
travail il faut avoir ça en tête l'offre
de travail qui va se donc par exemple
penser à hôtellerie restauration ou la
construction mais encore une fois c'est
ça doit être dit je pense que ça doit
être différencier et il faut pas penser
que le fait que les salaires augmentent
de manière différenciée dans la dans le
pays amène plus d'inégalités parce que
ça peut être aussi à rattrapage par
rapport à des situations antérieures qui
étaient inéquitable si on pense par
exemple aux travailleurs ce qu'on
appelait de deuxième ligne pendant la
crise covid
je reviens pas sur le débat sur la
productivité
donc sur le SMIC quel problème de fait
d'avoir une concentration au niveau du
SMIC alors la commission SMIC répète
année après année qui a un problème d'un
extinction du SMIC qui fait plus que ça
n'excès sur les prix qui est et donc il
mange progressivement les salaires qui
sont au-dessus donc on a périodiquement
ce problème du SMIC qui vient rattraper
les salaires qui sont au dessus et une
forme de désespérance et la France et un
pays de CDE peut-être le pays de l'OCDE
avec les salaires les plus concentrés et
donc qu'est-ce que ça pose comme
problème en période où il y a des chutes
de lois de monde ce qui est pas jusqu'à
aujourd'hui ça veut dire que le marché
du travail s'ajuste par du chômage
plutôt que par des baisses de
rémunération et en période comme
aujourd'hui et ben on a plein de gens
qui sont autour du SMIC il y a pas cette
différenciation dont on aurait besoin
pour s'ajuster aux contraintes de
recrutement qui sont encore une fois
très hétérogènes et les situations des
entreprises je suis parfaitement
d'accord avec Mathieu plane qui qui ont
des marges plus ou moins importante
selon où est-ce qu'elles sont placées
dans la chaîne de valeur est-ce qu'elles
peuvent ou non répercuter leur coûts ou
c'est très inéquate inéquitable inégale
liquides j'en sais rien illégale selon
les entreprises
donc ça c'est vraiment très important
alors sur la balance commerciale est-ce
grave
si on regarde le compte courant c'est
pas si grave finalement puisque on
rattrape avec des revenus ce qu'on perd
ce qu'on a pas en commercial par contre
si on regarde les performances à
l'export performance export de la France
ne sont pas bonnes elles étaient
améliorée et elle se sentent de nouveau
dégradées alors il y a des raisons
sectorielles les difficultés de
l'automobile l'aéronautique
l'aéronautique ça s'améliore ça
s'améliore ça va s'améliorer
l'automobile on sait pas encore
il y a vraiment ce sujet là
donc c'est plutôt parce que ça révèle
que en soi le devise commercial
alors sur la territoire ruraux quelle
mesure spécifique puisque effectivement
ça a été souligné plusieurs fois
dans la dans la loi pouvoir d'achat il y
a des mesures sur les gros rouleurs les
gens qui doivent obligatoirement prendre
la voiture pour aller au travail ça
c'est quand même principalement
territoire rural où il y a pas de
transport en commun et quand on regarde
ce sujet il faut faire aussi attention
quand rural le logement est moins cher
je parlais du loyer dans un instant et
normalement si le mécanisme de marché
fonctionne les loyers devraient baisser
en territoire rural parce que les gens
voudront plutôt se rapprocher des villes
pour avoir moins de coûts de transport
et
voilà alors justement j'en viens la
question des loyers j'en viens justement
à la question des loyers là on est il y
a vraiment un arbitrage à faire entre
prix et quantité puisque on sait que par
exemple sur les rediticité de
recrutement quand on interroge les
entreprises souvent c'est des questions
de logement c'est à dire que si elle
n'arrive pas à recruter c'est pas
forcément que le salaire ou les
conditions de travail ou c'est les
salariés trouvent pas de logement donc
ils vont pas venir il faut faire très
attention quand on a des mesures de de
blocage des loyers de décourager l'offre
de logement et on sait par exemple que
dans les grandes métropoles il y a eu
une il y a toujours une concurrence
entre la location longue durée et la
location touriste qui en a beaucoup
parlé donc ces sujets n'ont pas disparu
pour autant et on a un rebond d'ailleurs
du tourisme qui est spectaculaire en
France dont on peut se réjouir donc faut
faire un tout petit peu attention
et c'est aussi vrai pour le les livrets
A il faut pas non plus de décourager le
livre le logement social donc tout ça se
tient il faut faire très attention dans
la loi
pardon dans la loi le projet de loi
pouvoir d'achat il y a une un
plafonnement des hausses de loyer qui
proposait octobre 22 octobre 23 à 3 et
demi pour cent donc c'est c'est moi
qu'inflation mais c'est quand même pas
zéro pour pour essayer de faire cette
arbitrage
pour terminer l'assurépargne et
l'orientation de cette soirée pas la
consommation c'est sur épargne en
consommation ça a déjà été dit en agrégé
non
cette sur épargne n'est pas consommée
puisque on voit que au départ comme l'a
dit Mathieu et encore au dessus de son
niveau de la crise donc c'est bien
qu'elle continue de s'accumuler les deux
premiers défis comme l'a dit le CAE ont
consommé leur serait pas mais c'est eux
qui sont principalement visés par les
mesures d'indexation qui ont été donc
voilà c'est c'est eux qu'il faut
protéger et c'est le cas dans la
proposition de loi
maintenant
comment il faut pas regarder la sur
épargne uniquement à travers le livret A
il y a eu la loi pacte et qui a quand
même
conduit à une réorientation de l'épargne
plus il y a plus d'épargne longues
l'assurance vie un peu basculée sur les
unités de compte qui ont été plus
dynamiques notamment pendant la crise
covid donc il y a aussi des changements
au niveau européens des nouvelles
législations au niveau européen pendant
la Providence française de l'Union
européenne qui font que on améliore les
dispositifs pour l'investissement à long
terme donc ça c'est la mise par le long
terme c'est en particulier la transition
écologique donc ça c'est aussi important
voilà moi je vais m'arrêter là parce que
bon la parité euro-dollar là ah oui la
Chine juste un point sur la Chine alors
la Chine il y a deux effets sur
l'inflation il y a l'effet offre
perturbation des chaînes de valeur
etc donc ça c'est inflationniste c'est
clair mais il y a aussi un effet demande
et notamment l'effet pétrole
la Chine se réveillera du covid
la demande de pétrole au niveau mondial
réaugmentera mais actuellement ça plutôt
un effet des inflationniste alors j'ai
entendu un déconner chinois assuré avec
beaucoup d'aplomb que la contribution de
la Chine aujourd'hui à l'inflation
mondiale était négative donc j'ai quand
même quelques doutes mais bon c'est et
sur parité Euro Dollar je suis d'accord
ça nourrit l'inflation mais c'est quand
même un phénomène un peu du deuxième
ordre aujourd'hui par rapport à ce qu'on
ce qu'on est en train de vivre
bien merci nous concluons donc
maintenant cette
cette réunion
qui nous aura tenu deux heures mais avec
beaucoup d'intérêt à la fois sur les
thématiques et sur les apôts que vous
avez pu ajouter les uns et les autres
donc merci à tous les quatre d'être venu
jusqu'à nous ce matin nous avons
consacré ce temps et donc nous
souhaitons maintenant j'espère pour vous
tous quelques jours de repos peut-être
merci à tous en tout cas